a what à à
à à
anh alo alo chào các
Ở Đây Rồi mình yêu mình đăng nhập link trong thế kia mình sửa lại
ạ bây giờ trưa đến 8 giờ ông ạ 8 giờ người
bắt đầu cần nghiêm túc không ạ Thì giờ mình sẽ cho các bạn xem video
tự nhiên không ạ
phim chiến tranh mà
hãng 10 âm là người hâm Chị còn chiến tranh hả Ngày hôm nay có thể vắng hơn
đúng không
có mấy cái vụ liên quan gì nữa chính trị đấy thì à mình cũng có hóng
em làm hai ba ngày hôm nay mình mới có hóng thì da mình thích Lịch sự chứ mình
cũng không phòng cái kiểu dạng hỏng Điền lắm thì mình có Xem qua cái video tổng
hợp hãng Anh của kênh mới kênh đầy mình mới biết kênh
không phải sự những sự thật thú vị kênh gì thì cho vợ xem lại cái lấy tổng hợp
mình về chỉ trong vòng 5 phút thì phải có bạn
biết quà thì hay phết ừ ừ
ở
đây ok ăn canh kiến thức thú vị
1,4 triệu người theo dõi ý nghĩa chứng tỏ rất nhiều người quan
tâm là những kiến thức có sự thử mình nghĩ khá là ổn
chứ không phải kéo kiểu dạng mà những kênh tri thức thì ít
người theo dõi hơn cả mấy kênh nha Hai hạm Kiểu thế à
để kênh Ngày giải thích tôi thấy dễ hiểu phết hiểu qua được thôi không này hiểu
chi tiết lắm nhưng mà đầu hiểm vụ tai nạn mẹ về hai này à
Ừ thì đấy ở cái thứ mình đang bị nói cũng đề cập ở đây nên có lịch sử đó là
thực ra ai cũng nên kiểu Tìm hiểu lịch sự
học không phải mỗi lịch sử mà học là những cái liên quan những kiểu những cái
môn mà ở trên trường đã từng dậy nhưng mà thế do cách thầy cô dạy nữa tôi từng
thấy cô dạy lịch sử của tôi đọc cả lớp 10 ngủ và cô chẳng còn tâm nó là đứa bạn
đầu hãy cho mặt cô cũng ngủ và cũng chả quan tâm
Ừ tôi cũng là một đứa ban đầu tôi rất thích ngồi bàn đầu kiểu được chia tay
hỏi nói chuyện trực tiếp với thầy cô cũng như là ờ
có nhiều lý do nữa đại khái là đôi khi ở bị bắt lên ngồi lần đầu ngồi rồi gì ạ
Nói chuyện quá nhiều mất tập trung cứ cho em à đâu
Tôi ngồi ban đầu thì tôi không ngủ đâu nha mấy ông kia vẫn ngủ được rồi thật và
cụm những kệ đều đấy nữa là cô coi cái môn cô lại cảm thấy thì đúng là môn này
không phải muốn khi nhưng mà nó vẫn còn tính ở một mình quan trọng nếu mọi người
hùng thực sự yêu của nghề không phải yêu ngài giáo mà yêu về môn đấy đúng không
kiểu như thế họ sẽ muốn cố truyền nó sinh viên yêu cái môn đấy
Ừ nó ra nào giống như nào kiểu mấy ông học quốc phòng của học mấy cái chính trị
có thể chán Nếu mà gặp mấy thầy dạy quốc phòng mà từ quân đội ra ấy người người
của Đảng gậy buổi nó cái tầm khác khóc bọc hoặc hai dễ hiểu có thứ những người
ấy hiểu thực sự là kiểu có kinh nghiệm thực tế đúng không Cũng như là kiểu cách
nói chuyện nó khác hẳn nó không bị Rập khuôn máy móc lắm Kiều họ cũng nói họ
cũng cũng có nói là trong trong quân đội gặp có thành phần này hơn kia không ai
cậu chém gió Nhiều lúc nào tới sáng đúng không Nhưng mà họ cũng khiến cho tôi đấy
tôi học quốc phòng của mấy thầy thế bộ có cô nói dạo này mê viết kiểu vũ khí ở
mình em thích ở trong quân đội điều kiện môi
trường biển gặp những con người như thế hệ II
Hi hi cái việc đấy chưa truyền cảm ơn đây đúng không dạy học thì quan trọng là
như thế ta là hai lạc mềm đi bây lịch sử thôi nghĩa là ai cũng nên biết qua lịch
sử thời sự nước nhà mình công nhận ở rất nhiều cái hay nhưng mà thực sự ít người
biết là ít thứ chia sẻ hơn tôi từng xem cái video về lịch sử Việt Nam
không phải không phải là kiểu bộ môn Hóa chuyên hoang đang nhé Mà kiểu dạng cũng
không phải cửa hài cơ anh cũng kiểu ở hình minh họa có thiếu
thứ lại cũng khá là hay dễ hiểu cái tội mà khiến cho
cái video đấy tổng hợp quá à Nhanh ấy chỉ để cốt là để mà nói Tại sao đất nước
mình khi mở rộng bờ cõi được như bây giờ
thấy cũng khá hay A và
À mà cái kênh mà tôi đang định cho mấy ông
xe thì cũng sẽ nó qua Lịch sử nhưng mà không phải lịch sử Việt Nam là lịch sử
quốc tế thì ở Nhưng mà trước hết thì tôi cho ông xem cái đi dạo này nhiều cảnh
báo à Nó chửi bậy khá nhiều nhưng tôi sẽ giải thích tại sao tự nhiên tôi cho ông
xem cái video chị bận nhiều thì hết ok Ừ cái này phải yêu cầu đăng nhập the
[ __ ] sợ thì
ừ ừ
à à ừ ừ
à à à à
đã
cảnh báo bây giờ chị bảo nha mấy ông mà tâm hồn trọng sáng Thực ra là dưới 18
tuổi không nên xem em Em còn chơi 18 tuổi rồi thì toàn bộ hành vi hãy toàn bộ
hành động đều hành toàn bộ hành động gì nhở đều do
bạn quyết định nên là tôi không chịu trách nhiệm bất kỳ cái gì cả Ok câu hỏi
2 điều anh có bao nhiêu sợi tóc thế ngoài tắc của trên đầu ra mình còn có
tác của những khu vực khác nữa Nói chung là để đếm xem có bao nhiêu sợ thì cũng
hơi nhiều đấy Nói chung là nếu bạn muốn biết thì cái những góc riêng cho mình
Bạn có thể đến gặp mình và đến hộ mình có phải ba thu nhập hàng tháng của anh
là bao nhiêu Nói chung là đủ để đáp ứng những nhu cầu các bạn như là ăn đùi nhỉ
Bạn có hỏi bậy anh có phải là gay không đây Có lẽ là một trong những câu hỏi của
mình nhận được nhiều nhất giữa các bạn và video nào mình đăng lên cũng có người
hỏi câu này ngay ở trên wikipedia có nghĩa là người đồng tính nam là những
người đàn ông có xu hướng thôi thúc để tình cảm và tình dục hướng về những
người đàn ông khác theo mình thì cái định nghĩa này nó không đúng với mình
lắm mình biết là những cái trò đùa của mình có thể sẽ khiến nhiều người nghĩ
mình là bêđê Tuy nhiên Thật ra nam với nữ đối mình nó không quan trọng có thời
gian để của mình có hứng thú thì nam hay nữ mình cũng sợ hết Nhưng mà nếu bạn hỏi
mình là mình có thích chim không tặc có thích con trai không thì mình có còn nếu
bạn hỏi và mình có phải là hay không thì mình không phải là ngay nam nữ quan
trọng [ __ ] gì miễn sướng là được câu hỏi 10 Thành sắc mới địt mẹ anh thấy đi Cửa
Lò nhà mày có hỏi 12 nếu không làm YouTube thì anh sẽ làm gì
nếu không làm YouTube thì có lẽ là mình sẽ bay về Nhật Bản để làm diễn viên đóng
phim Má có hỏi 15 Anh ơi những thứ vô dụng nhất khi chiến tranh là gì ạ Bạn
hỏi câu này khó vãi [ __ ] mình chị sẽ biết trả lời thế nào Câu hỏi 17 Anh ơi sao
mỗi lần nói chuyện cái mắt anh không Biểu cảm gì vậy Mình bị đứt dây thần
kinh điều cả nào câu 20 Anh có đang làm gì khác ngoài YouTube không ạ Ngoài này
trước ra thì mình vẫn như cách thường xuyên phải là ý của mình là phục vụ
khách hàng nhà mình là có năng mà câu 21 Anh ơi vẽ manga thì nộp bản thảo ở đâu
vậy Kéo Ai mà biết được câu 22 mất hứng vẽ thì làm gì hả anh đừng có lẽ nữa cậu
23 anh thuận tay nào mình thợ xây phải 10 25 anh xem phim 18 + chưa ạ Mình là
một con người rất là văn minh của trong sáng không bao giờ biết xem phim 18 cộng
nhá Mình chỉ sẽ phim khiêu dâm thôi Câu 26 luyện tập thế nào để mau lên tay quay
tay nhiều và lên không 28 muốn kiếm tiền từ hội họa theo anh có những cách nào ta
mà biết chị đã giàu từ lâu rồi câu29 Anh có người yêu chưa chưa Mày câu 32 Anh ăn
gì mà đẹp trai thế ạ Mình chưa bao giờ nghĩ rằng mình là người đẹp trai cho đến
khi đọc được câu hỏi này Ok thì mình cũng sẽ chia sẻ với các bạn có chế độ ăn
uống của mình Mình rất là thích ăn những loại hoa quả Nhiệt Đới ví dụ như là dưa
hấu và bưởi những cái loại quả mà có nhiều dinh dưỡng như là chuối và nho
Ngoài ra thì mình cũng phải ăn các loại sữa chua để giữ cho làn da luôn được mịn
màng và tốt cho hệ tiêu hóa nữa Câu 33 Anh trải qua bao nhiêu mối tình rồi ạ
Mình còn riêng một trăm phần trăm chưa từng yêu ai và cũng chưa từng tay
Ờ tôi chỉ buồn cười cái đoạn mà không ấy bảo là trai gái đều thích nhưng mà lại
kêu chưa từng yêu ai hơi kiểu đó nhạc trữ tình chạy
video vừa rồi thật cả bệnh khá là bậy nó không hiểu dạng giống kiểu vibox JV
Evermind đã từng cho bit những cái đoạn đấy mà chửi thẳng luôn Nếu mọi người
không biết ở ga kiểu người Bắc Trung Chắc là thế ngày Hà Nội à cháu lấy người
Hà Nội thanh lịch Cá thứ nhưng mà sẵn hàng có thể gửi những cái cầu khá là
kiểu nghe cái nhiệt nó cũng và gọi nhà nó xát muối hơn khá nhiều so với dân ở
chỗ khác tôi tôi ở đây có biết mà mẹ tôi một điển hình rồi Mà tôi cũng tôi cũng
có thể chửi khiến cho người khác khóc có ấy nhé Ừ nhưng mà
không thể tôi nói thế Ok Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau cùng nhau ngay chửi hay
là từ nay có giữ như vậy hay gì cả mà tôi Tôi đang nói việc là tôi vừa nói là
tôi có một người mẹ chửi
nghe hay như hát luôn Nếu mà mỗi tội là hai khi mình gọi bạn đã nhân còn nếu
mình như là dở luôn khóc khóc ở đấy thì
thế nên là tôi từng Ghét cái đấy của mẹ đây là
ờ ờ tôi từng hứa thể cho thử là sẽ không phải chửi vậy đến năm lớp 10 đ
xe nâng cấp 2 tội từng bị một đứa lửa nói câu [ __ ] má
ấy vậy mà Nhưng mà Đấy bị lừa một lần này thôi nói
chúc vợ tôi kiểu đã từng thế nhưng mà tại sao đến năm lớp 10 rồi vậy nó tự
nguyện chị bạn nói Tại sao bởi vì hồi nãy tôi xem JVevermind
có và anh để sẽ đầu độc tôi trở thành con người mới dậy mà là anh ấy nói việc
xử thê tất cả chửi người khác nó khác nhau chị thể được hỏi đều bộc lộ cảm xúc
mà thoải mái hơn Cứ thứ cách nói chuyện đỗ kiểu
những tố quá Vì thế nên là tôi nghĩ à Nó bình thường hơn một tí hồi đấy là tôi
Anh chỉ nói những cái kiểu đời mà mờ bây giờ nói tắt thôi chứ không làm nói thằng
phô ra nhớ về sau kiểu cũng cũng quen cho vợ chửi hề chú ý chửi người ta chửi
thề nhiều sau đó thì đương nhiên là tôi thấy Ẩm Thực ra nó vẫn làm cái gì đó khá
là khó nghe Sao vậy Sao tôi học cách chửi nghe hay để rồi Tôi chỉ nghe hay
nói bây giờ bất kỳ đứa bạn nào rỗi từ ngày tôi tôi chửi nó rồi mà bọn nó đều
cười nhưng mà tôi chửi nó cơ cho bọn nó điều cười cơ tôi chửi nó mà
nó vẫn cười ấy ông phải làm sao cho ông có cái độ duyên như hệ Thưa ông ấy nên
chửi hệ con mua khi mà ông mà nói chuyện mà khiến cho người kia khó nghe thì kể
cả Ông nói câu Không phải chữa bệnh thì người kiện không muốn nghe đơn giản thế
thôi ông ạ Còn mỗi khi mà ông nó hiểu cậu vào đỡ nha cái tâm của ông không
phải là ông nói móc thì người ta ông - để người ta thật là ý là kiểu nó bình
thường hóa lên đấy thì mọi thứ bình thường nhưng mà nhưng vẫn là cổ Nhưng đó
là những lúc mà Rồi cần nghiêm túc truyền hình những lúc tôi dậy như này kể
cả thuyền trưởng thế tôi có thân và sinh viên Tôi từng nói là tôi thường hay bảo
mẹ em đấy Gọi tôi là anh vì thế thì tôi muốn thân thoải mái với mấy đứa đấy đúng
không Em yêu nhà tầng chửi bọn nó rồi mà bữa lên chửi vợ tao không tất cả cùng
cười mấy hạt khác nữa thằng cười rồi bà đấy giấy này cũng cười
Ừ nhưng mà khi mà dậy tôi sẽ nghiêm túc không có mời Chửi bậy không ngờ đùa cợt
một cái gì trong lớp cả đứng yên là có kiểu dạng là nói chuyện kiểu dáng kiểu
thân hiện kiểu như bây giờ này kiểu gì thả pha cho họ cũng như bây giờ này
Nhưng tôi sẽ không đùa cợt cụ thể phải bất kỳ sinh viên nào bởi vì lúc dậy ở
Tôi sẽ rất nghiêm túc thôi giờ không thiên vị đối xử với ai Tớ làm công bằng
nghĩa lúc mà mình cần người lớn thì mình sẽ thể hiện mình là mình con lúc mà trẻ
trâu ấy mời ông đi nét Chúng tôi sẽ biết
cô sinh viên tôi từng kệ nhé Tôi cũng cùng sinh viên của linus sau đó thì kiểu
ờ ờ số mệnh miệng bạn nó gặp nó rồi bảo
không ai đi lấy cùng ai đi nét cùng thầy rồi được rồi chỉ vợ tôi tôi đang ngồi
vừa bắn vừa chửi cái chắc là thầy vào Ấy guitar với hơn
buồn cười cực kỳ Có những lúc đấy mình khi mà đi chơi thì
mình phải thoải mái thoải mái suốt đấy đúng không đứng yên cái đội hỏa Máy của
tôi không có giới hạn đó là tôi không rượu bia không chữ kích thích nhưng mà
rủ tôi đi Cậu đi đâu tội có thể đi đi qua đêm nói phải đi Đấy cái phương châm
của tôi nhất là mình có tài chính nữa Đến thứ
hai mình có thời gian khi mình đã dành cho bạn bè anh em cứ tự thứ mình dễ giả
máy nó cái mình đi đâu mình vẫn phải đi theo
nó và đi khi nào mà toàn cuộc cùng về kiểu như thế
có thể tính thôi à là Mày làm bên mình học học thêm mình
còn chơi cũng chơi hết mình nhưng mà không chơi mà cái chất kích thích không
chơi rượu bia vì nó hại hại không phải hạn mỗi sức khỏe hại thần kinh nữa mình
con người làm thần kinh mình kiếm tiền hay là mọi thứ như đó đúng không nên đầu
óc mình ở luôn tỉnh nào Ừ Ok tôi nói mấy con điện mà rồi thế chả
mấy ông cũng hiểu mà đúng không
ở trường chơi những lúc hát karaoke tôi mày uống có tí bia lên nó dạng thôi à
à mà chơi ở nhà ông không nói chuyện với ai thì trở gì Nhưng mà nếu mà tôi mà thử
gọi em bạn để trộn gì đấy mẹ tôi mấy thằng ngay cũng kéo ở thai biết gì vậy à
về từ trước cái với ngoan mà nhưng mà dần dần thì cũng thấy kiểu bình thường
hơn tí thôi Nhưng mà mấy lần thì cũng cắt à
ở nhà tôi nói thế thì ăn chỉ là mấy ông mà
sau khi mở Tôi nói rồi đấy 18 tuổi đúng không qua cái ngưỡng này đi thì mình bắt
đầu nhận thức được mọi hành động của mình rồi là mọi thứ cũng nên
em suy nghĩ một tí nói có gì nên suy nghĩ không phải muốn có thể vậy nhưng mà
chửi vậy thì tôi không coi nó là một vấn đề Nếu mà gọi đó kiểu chửi bậy trong mà
tôi thôi không có để người mới dậy chậm như thế người Thái Bình thường thôi bộc
lộ cảm xúc của họ Vân đấy nhưng mà ở những cái lúc quan trọng những giây
phút quan trọng là ngon mình sẽ phải nói những câu
em có văn hóa một tí đúng không Thế thôi cho ví dụ điển hình giống như ông nào
hỏi tôi về xăm nhà bạn sẽ không coi người xăm người như nào đấy
anh đúng không thấy mình mình có những cái
thế giới hạn những cái kiểu thước đo mình đặt ra thì ông sẽ làm được mọi thứ
Ôi tôi tin như thế Con người tôi từng xem cái phim The transporter Người Vận
Chuyển đi tôi rất thần tượng anh đấy vì bởi vì anh
ấy cậu trong bộ phim đấy hỏi chung ích cái gì đó đã ta những cái nội quy góp
của người đàn ông đã Thế cậu có muốn cái gì đó khẳng định luôn đối mấy bạn nữ xem
mấy kiểu thể bị cuốn hút lắm đúng không những kiểu
học còn chứng kiến họ đã là những quy tắc viết tắt của tên heo nó đứng yên là
vẫn phải vì một mỹ nhân ở đó nhưng mà khi họ sống có cái tắc miền Bắc như thế
xong rồi chín đi mình rèn được cái như thế mình
sẽ nói được người khác mà có trọng lượng lời nói của trọng lượng người khác sẽ để
mình à Mà ông thầy xong tao thì đấy để người
khác điều này đúng không tính thế ngoài đời thật đấy anh xem cái đấy tán được em
ạ Ừ ok 8 giờ thôi rồi nhưng mà vẫn hay một
con kia hôm nay nhóm gì hết rồi đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ quay quay nhóm cá nhóm để các
nhóm chuẩn bị trước đã rồi tôi sẽ tâm sự nốt và chợ có họ này cho vẻ đông người
on hơn thì mình bắt đầu bảo vệ nha Hôm trước bảo vệ Hình như nhóm mục rồi
đúng không sẽ lại danh sách vật Anh bảo vệ những nhóm gì hiểu nhé
em cũng khổ quá anh không con người mà sống không có
nguyên tắc không có quy tắc thì tôi cảm thấy là nó giống như kiểu có người từng
nói nó giống kiểu động vật đi khi dùng từ hơi thô một tí nhưng mà nó thế
Ừ bởi tôi từng nghe có lấy tôi một cái video ở đó rồi
hiểu con người thật có những nguyên tắc quy tắc riêng có quy chuẩn đạo đức riêng
nghệ và Văn Ngọc không cần phải nhất thiết phải theo phải giống ai nhưng mà
nói chung mà mình phải có những cái thứ mình không ngờ làm những thứ mình có dạy
làm và Vân đúng rồi bạn viên ở đúng không nguyên tắc thể loạn không phải nói
về mỗi về luật phát hay gì cả mà nó là mình thật tự tạo như em đã quy tắc riêng
mình ạ dù trong trường hợp nào mình đỡ phải làm này trong trường hợp này sẽ vào
cái kia ngon mình phải biết đúng sai thì nó mới ổn không
thế âm thanh ngang hơi nhỏ để tôi dí vào mic
Ê mấy ông nói chung à Tôi không phải là người mà thương anh kêu gọi đổi nết
nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ chiều mày ông khi ông muốn gì cũng chưa
à à Anh à hôm trước à
bí ngô rồi nhỉ nhóm nào nhỉ Không phải sửa mới
ờ ờ Ồ thông thì sát mặt vào cái mic đấy ở
nhóm 1 nhóm A Anh không thích làm ba rồi đúng không
thôi Cái xử mất đỡ bảo vệ nhóm ảo thôi nhóm 21 Hôm trước bác mua hôm trước thì
hôm nay vẫn có thể nhé hả Thôi là tạm bỏ bớt đi để nhường đường thời gian nóng
khác nhiều nhóm cho mệt
- 14h đúng không Ok thế thì còn à
36 rồi à Hôm trước bảo vệ cũng
từ tương đối rồi từ hôm nay bây giờ đủ đủ chưa nhỉ Mà mình quay ngẫu nhiên nha
chú chó bề nhóm 2 xin Chả hiểu sao thấy kiểu Toàn lên đầu nhóm 2 nhóm 16 Đúng
không mấy cái Ngó Mày chuẩn bị sẵn tinh thần trước đi rồi tôi sẽ copy trước ra
ừ ừ
à à Ê mày không biết tại sao tôi phải copy ở
đây đâu mà khóc đi lại và kia không phải lần trước tôi copy từ đây xong rồi vào
thẳng vào thẳng trong này nó bị gấu nó sát vào nhau cái nắp lại biến thành xác
là nhờ cay Vãi cả như tốt làm cái loại này ghét vãi
từ hôm ấy ông nhỉ được mà đúng Ừ thôi sao tôi gửi rõ à những nhóm Sao
chuẩn bị nhé 2
à à Ừ ừ nữa sẽ ghi rồi nhỉ
Cai nhỉ không Dạ không sao có cách chúng là vẫn có cách
thì mình sẽ đổi ở nhớ xuống dòng là gạch chéo n ở trong
cái đó xong mình sẽ đổi thành dấu này ở đó thế xong
à à
ở đây Chưa chúng ta dân cũng nghệ mà Okay
tiếp tục Ừ thì vừa rồi là cái cái cái video tâm
tâm sự kiểu question-answer đồng ngon là họ những
câu hỏi thường gặp phải trả lời giống kiểu em à Quý và phim i
ờ ờ hỗn Asus Ô Kìa
mình cũng sẽ trả lời những câu hỏi mà nhiều người thường hay hỏi mình các bạn
có thể hỏi thêm nhé để mình tổng hợp luôn Video hôm nay cũng sẽ một video
tổng hợp luôn khá nhiều ý kiến cá nhân của mình cũng như là những câu hỏi và
tiện hệ thì mình cũng nói qua đó là do sự có cũng có bạn hỏi mình và thời
gian nếu mà chưa ai hỏi mình cứ tự trả lời đó là
Nếu giả sử mà dậy xong khóa khóa sau là tháng 7 tháng 8 thì gì đó thì kênh này
của mình sẽ làm gì không ạ Cái này của mình mình đã từng nói thì có thể đó hình
hỏa Thỉnh thoảng thôi mình có thời gian mình sẽ ngồi lai cốt Nhưng mà nếu thấy
sẽ không đăng gì trong suốt một thời gian dài mình thấy cũng hay cũng như hết
ý tưởng là đúng không Thì mình sẽ chơi trò là tận dụng lại những cái video cũ
như thế này chỉ cách những cái mẫu có thể tâm sự hoặc là màu những kể mấy cái
kiểu thông tin kiến thức gì đó kiểu chó đấy kiểu ngắn để mà đăng lên sót vẫn cả
Tik Tok hay mọi cái mạng xã hội khác
Ừ thì hôm trước mình có đọc một cái của một cánh phải game đó là kèo lúc đấy
mình mới biết mà mình mới để ý đó là kẻ nhiều kênh tách ra thành kênh riêng liên
quan đến xót Bởi vì nếu mà Ừ nếu mà kiểu
tạo cách tạo sót như thế đông là nhiều người biết đến thậm chí nhiều người lướt
qua lại biết đến cách mình nhưng mà bù lại thì cái lượng thời gian trung bình
Xem của kênh sẽ bị giảm bởi vì cái sọt Nó chỉ có một phút thôi tự nhiên là
thành ra là hiểu thành ra là cái vi bình thường Mới ông
xem video tôi hơn tiền ngon thì trung bình thời gian xem mình có thể ít nhất
là hơn một phút Khoa học Tự nhiên thành ra thời gian trung bình của kênh sẽ bị
giảm từ ra tôi không quan tâm mình cái điều đấy tôi đã từng nói là tôi không
quan tâm một cái điều đấy Tôi chỉ không quan tâm việc và mình cần
có như nào đấy vận sẽ chạy quảng cáo được Hải Vân tôi chỉ quan tâm mày vừa có
người biết đến Có người biết đến còn họ hiểu thấy cần mình thì tốt còn không thì
thôi mà cũng không cần phải phổ biến đến nỗi lời dịu dàng mà chạy gì gì đó nên là
tôi vẫn sẽ làm một cái nghề thôi Tôi muốn ở kiểu nên lên Google tôi vẫn muốn
ở Vì sao lên Google gõ không phải gọi tên tôi thì ra nữa Sao không đến lượt
đâu nhưng gọi gì alo chẳng hạn thì nó xảy ra tất cả cách mạng xấu của tôi này
mà mọi người thể vào xem học được thì thì tốt chia sẻ chia sẻ cho cái người mà
cũng có nhu cầu đúng không
cho cháu hỏi mình còn chưa làm với con chatbox các thử nếu mà về trọng sẽ cạn ý
tưởng thôi Bởi vì có những cái nó rất là dài khó mặc cốt trong vòng 1 tiếng được
ờ ờ
thì Đấy mình sẽ ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ trả lời những câu hỏi thường gặp trước đã
nhé các bạn có thể hỏi luôn
ở đâu ạ Những câu hỏi Sinh nhật mình vừa được Ê một ít ở đây này mới nhất mình
bao nhiêu tuổi thực ra là cái có mày được hỏi khá nhiều lại từ những cái bạn
mà kiểu ví dụ ở tôi livestream ngay dẫn rất nhiều Bạn có thể nhiều bạn mới thấy
cách của tôi vào thứ hai hỏi tôi cũng này cũng như tôi học trường nào
À mà tôi tên là gì nữa thi Ừ mình sinh năm 97 mình không phải sinh
năm 96 mình học à ở Học viện Công nghệ hỏi lấy tên là Học
Viện Công Nghệ Thông Tin Bách Khoa B Kate Còn bây giờ đổi tên là Học viện
Công nghệ mới các em bỏ về điện Bách Khoa đi bởi vì để tránh
việc dinh gì với khoa Hồi trước và thử cao đến mấy giờ thì vẫn dính dính nhưng
mà dính dáng cao là người quá Khoa nhưng mà nhiều người khác hiểu nhầm xong đại
học Bách Khoa Thế là mình 97 thôi chứ không phải 96 không phải là 96
học cơ khí đổi nhanh sáng bách xanh lập trình
lập trình khi nào mình hợp liệu trình như như đa số các bạn tính ở Hà Nội đó
là học lập trình Pascal hồi cấp ba từ hồi cấp ba thì mình mình là cái thằng mà
động máy tính trước rất nhiều đứa nên thành ra mình không ngại việc học không
phải mỗi lập trình mà học các văn phòng mình cảm thấy ổn cái này ra là mình dễ
tiêu Thu Cuối cùng thì cả lớp cũng không cũng lười không đó làm mình tò mò thằng
làm nhánh là lớp 2 giờ trình độ của mình hồi đấy mình tự kiêu trình độ mình khá
ổn hãy cỡ thế mà cô giáo cũng định hướng nhà và cho mình theo ngành này thì đấy
cũng là một lý do một nhóm khá nhiều lý do mình chọn ngày này
vì những lí do mình chọn này thứ nhất thì mình tiếp xúc của máy tính từ hồi 2
tuổi thành ra cũng không Bạn Lỡ với nó thì chơi mình ngồi cày ngày đêm với nó
được thứ hai đó là mình đã từng thích về kiến
trúc sư tôi từng kể vụ này nhá hơi đấy tôi hồi cấp 2 tán một bạn sinh trong lớp
Thế thích mỗi bạn đấy rồi cả hồi cấp 2 mình mà toàn xịt dại gái hồi đấy Đấy bây
giờ vẫn dại gái như hội này em mình đúng nghĩa là mình không biết bạn gái mình bị
vào Khanh tôi là nhiều người thế bạn đấy cả năm cả
hai ba năm cấp hai đấy À mà thôi Đấy mình thổ lộ tâm sự với bạn
đấy là mình lại muốn làm kỹ sư và sau này muốn thiết kế phòng mình tôi định
nói với là thiết kế phòng tôi Thành à ờ ờ
ở phòng hậu của Lầu Năm Góc xanh đậu xanh
vẫn cười vậy à
Anh nói hồi nãy định nói là Lầu Năm Góc nói
bạn kiểu váy da bây giờ các bạn không ngờ đâu đấy là một
trong những cái máy rửa nhưng mà ngồi đấy Tôi học công nghệ rất
là giỏi nhá Mẹ con thứ tôi từng đi thi công nghệ về vẽ cho thứ thử
à Nhưng mà ngành kiến trúc sư rồi đúng à cần phải
giỏi vẽ các thử nữa tôi không giỏi cái đấy lắm tôi rõ bên Vật Lý không khỏi cái
đấy thôi Sau đó thì về sau tôi còn định làm luật sư Vì nhiều người bảo tôi gọi
cãi sau đó thì tôi cố định theo ngành báo thì tôi rất thích nói là những ý
tưởng của mình nhưng mà kể cả là sự hai báo thì tôi vẫn bạch Bởi vì môn Văn ở
tôi không được điểm cao thì tôi không ngờ theo ý của cô giáo
à à anh
em thành ra là tôi không vào mấy chương kia được
ơi con có người hỏi tôi tại sao không làm sư
phạm của bạn thế thôi anh vẫn là vạch môn Văn thậm chí là tôi
vạch trường đại học cũng là bởi vì A môn Văn chẳng hiểu tôi vẫn cảm đến bây giờ
vẫn không hiểu lại sao lại học Hà Nội cái khối công nghệ thông tin
ông ngoại tuyển a10 phải tuyển Hà không phải không Không thể nói một là chuyển
B1 nghĩa là phải cần Văn vãi chưởng I hear
ở đảo xa trường gửi toàn tôi nói thẳng là kiểu Thằng Em Tôi học trường đấy công
nghệ không tìm và nó khẳng định rồi chán ở Đại học Hà Nội Tâm vẫn cay Nếu mà
không Sao tôi cảm thấy may mà tôi không vào mình vào trường đợi khi Nhà tôi ở
trên phố rồi đấy phóng về đây mười mấy cây đi học sợ đó
khi chúng tôi cảm thấy may mắn thì tôi á trường đại học để vào trường này
ở rõ ra là đã ở tuyển A1 đúng không Nhưng mà không để B1 vào khối công nghệ
thông tin hệ giữa mình cười à ờ ờ
anh ngồi tiếp theo mức lương bao nhiêu lương của mình hiện tại là mới chính
hiệu nó khá là thấp sao bưởi năng lượng thực sự của mình mình phải dùng từ như
thế bởi vì mình đánh giá qua việc là khá nhiều Hết rồi khỏi mình cũng như là
nhiều nơi gạo mình về mức lương cao hơn nên mình nghĩ là thế nhé Mà thực ra mình
cũng nói qua vụ tâm sự về cái vụ lưu lương này đó ra à mình hiện tại mình
sống Thái thoải mái rồi nên là thành ra là không không
Anh không quan trọng về việc tăng thêm lương nữa chạy chứa tôi tăng lên khá
nhiều ô tô hiện đại là mười 19 triệu còn chưa
1.000 đô đúng không là lúc khởi điểm mới vào tôi 15 triệu
sau rồi Lúc đầu tôi còn định là chị lúc đầu vào chắc là 10 triệu thôi Bây giờ
tôi năm kinh nghiệm với tao vẫn hơn ít thôi tôi biết làm như là năm kinh nghiệm
ít nhưng mà anh xếp thì sẽ thoải mái vào mức lực tối thiểu cái công ty này hiện
tại là 15 triệu nên mua vào tôi vẫn 15 triệu công ty tôi là công ty áp thực ra
nó cả đáng lẽ thường mà lương nó sẽ khá ít và khó tăng lương khó tăng lương bởi
giai đoạn này vẫn giai đoạn như cậu vẫn còn đang nào
vi phạm nhạc công ty có chưa có doanh thu mấy vẫn còn bị lỗi giờ cậu khó tăng
lương với vụ này chỉ cốt là được phần trăm cổ phần do một về sau được hưởng
cái gì đó để tội không nắm rõ luôn à Ừ nếu mà tôi Chính vì thế và tôi cũng
anh gọi nhiều mình được gà mình cả ngày dấu tối cả hai mới tính lại tao cũng có
sử dụng tiền ấy đâu thỉnh thoảng có nhiều tiền tự nhiên hướng lên đi mua cái
gì đó thôi còn không giới ít khi đi ăn mua sắm đi cả giờ cậu nó
Ừ nó kéo không ăn chậm lắm Ê bà tôi tính tao lại không thích kiểu
gì cao mấy cái này nhưng mà tôi cũng định nói mấy ông đó là ờ
Ê mấy ông cũng có thể không cần này như
tôi không cần phải con người tự thể hiện mình liêm khiết à Xong rồi biểu không
tham lam gì cả em về quyền lợi của mấy ông nhìn mấy ông
vẫn nên kêu gọi và nên kiểu đòi cái lợi các thử thứ IV bởi vì riêng công ty tôi
thì do Sếp tôi hiểu xếp như thế nào và cậu tớ cũng thương thế phải dùng từ như
thế này ăn mới thế còn nhiều xét thì đúng nghĩa bóc lột giống như công ty
công ty đầu tiên tôi làm từng nói là tôi làm nó công ty đấy lượng cũng công ty
pháp đi thực tập thì hồi nãy tôi được đeo bọt 500 xong rồi cái sau lên mình
một triệu nhưng mà khi mà tao làm được việc rồi họ vẫn chỉ Chả tôm một triệu do
sếp sếp đấy con người không cố tình bóc lột sức lao động thúc đẩy tông lấy bỏ
việc là bởi vì tôi điều lương không được nữa thì tôi mới bỏ việc nghĩa là khi mà
âm thực sự ông làm được việc họ phải trân trọng ông
bà con ở đây tôi vẫn thấy cách xếp chân chậm tôi có thử sướng này là tôi vẫn
thoải mái về lương nó không nắm kẻ bằng việc và xếp ông có tôn trọng ông không
thực sự là như thế đấy ông ạ hai phần như tôi đã nói thì công ty tôi
vẫn đang bị ạ cậu doanh thu nhưng ra tôi cũng hiểm có nhiều ông đồng nghiệp của
tôi cũng Nam kêu gọi đò thiên lương mà không hề quan tâm với việc của sếp đăng
như thế nào đang có vấn đề như thế nào Ừ thế này lành ra tôi cũng không thích
kiểu nữ
1001 tạo thêm áp lực cho ai ai ai cũng muốn dễ thở muốn cuộc sống này Thoải mái
thôi họ thoải mái mình khá nhiều Tôi bảo vào công ty thì thôi từ lỗ để nhưng mà
sếp vẫn cố hết sức nha Tôi từng khoe ở xếp tặng cho nhân viên có thử bao nhiêu
thứ rồi xong rồi ở mỗi tháng thì đầu tư nước riêng nước ngọt đã hơn mấy triệu
mỗi tháng Xong rồi chiều nào cũng cho cũng gọi đồ ăn vặt cho anh em cứ thứ
nghĩa xếp cô thoải mái hết sức có thể nhưng mà
Ừ anh em vẫn đòi họ hơn thì À thì ra là làm khó sẽ Tôi nghĩ gì nữa
hết cho tôi không đòi hỏi mình từ đây cái
chỉ đó hỏi cậu được công nhận là cái dự thứ chả tính tôi như thế
ở công ty của tôi tôi biết được về việc là nhiều anh em ở đây sẽ sẵn sàng cậu ở
ví dụ Tính ở quảng cáo công ty thôi Cái gì đó vào về cộng đi Tôi làm gì gì đó
không phải nhưng mà Bởi vì A Dính về rình thứ nhất là rình với anh Tuấn ơi
mình này anh em Uta ga tôi không không khó một công khai được thế còn nhiều ông
nhìn qua Biết rồi mà nhìn qua biết thôi công ty nào rồi
khi bé gần nhất thứ hai là vì công ty tôi lại hướng đến thị trường
bên nước ngoài nè hàng ra là cũng mời anh em không giúp được gì nhiều đâu nên
phải giờ tôi mà Cùng lắm là tôi chỉ mong anh em
nào về sau làm được việc A và mà quan trọng Đấy chí nữa tôi sẽ đề
cao rất nhiều cái thì sẽ mà cỏ Chị cũng chí không Bởi vì công ty vẫn đang cần
tuyển những người đưa ra những cái con đi sát luôn tuyển những người tiên phong
và những người phải phải gắn bó lâu dài chứ không phải kiểu hướng lên thì nghỉ
đúng không có người nào nhỉ người kia sẽ bị làm
theo ấy bây giờ kiểu sẽ phải cần người cùng chí cung làm cùng
Ừ để nhanh đồ ăn hay được không Ý em là sao nhỉ
ờ ờ ở phía sau này lương cao cũng đúng nhau
Thực ra tôi không tình yêu việc rồi bà xã để vào đường cao mà tôi tính thích và
xã bởi vì áo kiểu có rất nhiều thứ để học và rất nhiều thứ để làm chưa vào làm
cậu công ty to sẵn đấy nó sẽ nhược điểm mà ông chỉ động vào một mảnh thôi
cho mấy công ty có nhận nhân viên parttime
không cá ngành Công nghệ thông tin này thì loại rất khó để nhận parttime mọi
việc em cần em làm là một thứ đôi khi là không tính và tiếng không tính vào thời
gian làm ở trên công ty không đâu mà em phải cần làm xong công việc đấy nếu mà
giờ xử em vào hai ba tiếng mỗi ngày mà sao được tính năng thì chẳng ai Ké này
cả Nhưng mà thường mày chắc chắn là tối nó nhiều thời gian hơn thế
vì Hủy hợp đồng lao động Tôi từng nghĩa vụ việc Hủy hợp đồng ngay các từ ngữ
thức là khác chạm một vài công ty sẽ sẽ kiểu đòi các thử thứ nhưng mà thực là
tôi tôi từng nghe và anh bảo đi chẳng công ty ở kiện em đâu em hết thích thì
em nghỉ được Tôi không biết này nó ở bọn này đâu nhé
Ẩm Thực tập viết các mẫu giao diện thì được bao nhiêu ạ
anh ra biết về mẫu giao diện đã rồi Nếu mà kiểu các bạn theo ngành công nguyện
tin này thì nên biết lập trình mà thực ra ở các bạn đừng có ham đi làm Bây giờ
chị kiếm một ít như thế kiếm Thương Tí Tí mua Thế cố học để mà làm thẳng đứng
cái gì ở ổn ông ngoại theo hết ví dụ khóa nâng cao
Thứ hai này thì chất và nó các bạn lương sẽ ra ổn các bạn sẽ không ở nghĩ việc nó
có tiền mình không vân vân nữa ở công ty nào không Yêu cầu phải lên ông
tỉa thường là bây giờ là biện dịch này ông thích nhìn được nhớ phải công ty là
thoải mái ví dụ công ty to thì thường vẫn yêu cầu lên vì nó có nhiều chính
sách các thứ liên quan nhiều phòng 3 nữa còn ví dụ giống như công ty tôi thì bé
được mua nhà được biết được dịch này mà tôi vợ từ đợt dịch đến giờ tôi gần Chắc
chắn là hơn tháng rồi ở thôn 6 tháng có tuổi trở lên công gì
ở tuổi à
Em làm được một trang web tin tức cùi đi được tập được không ạ
Tại sao các bạn cứ ha mà vụ đi thực tập để làm gì khi mà về cơ bản đi học tập
thì người ta vẫn sẽ đào tạo lại các bạn mà các bạn vẫn sẽ phải tự học ở nhiều
nếu mà các bạn mà cảm thấy học ở nhà tự học không ổn thì các bạn mày lên đi để
có người chúc còn không thì các bạn nên tự ở nhà học xong rồi tự
tự cố làm phẳng được một cái gì ở ổn đấy á giống như cái đồ ăn hai tô vào đây thì
các bạn sẽ đỡ phải mất thời gian bên công ty để ngồi Lan khác gì Ngồi làm nhà
đâu
Anh không quan trọng 10 năm năm học đâu ông ạ Các bạn học cấp ba người ta vẫn
thì chuyện các bạn họ và đánh giá cao những người có trí như thế à
a tiếp theo ngày tổ quốc bao nhiêu tiếng cho tôi đã từng nói là tôi cài cái tiện
ích để mà biết được mỗi ngày tôi có bao nhiêu tiếng nhưng mà thực tế nó không
quan tâm mà việc ngày tôi có bao nhiêu tiếng tôi cứ dậy rồi tôi mở máy
khi tôi ngồi Cốt Ừ tôi có nó một thứ gì đó khá là đam mê Khả Cập à quên hết cả
thời gian nó đúng rồi đam mê đấy Khi mà mày ông dùng thử Đam mê là một cái gì đó
là ông sẽ kiểu làm miệt mài không quên quên cả ăn và ngủ quên cả thời gian tôi
ông Chấn nhận ra tối rồi em ạ Chứ ông mà còn ngồi bấm giờ 2 ở ông ngồi làm chỉ đủ
tắm giếng là gì thì nó thì một là ông là con người rất là ra khuôn mẫu được đánh
giá cao hay ông có đấy chị việc làm việc làm thì thực ra thì ông coi nó việc làm
thì ông ấy khó anh khó yêu thích nó khó kiểu dạng nào ở
đấy say mê vì nó như thế khó tiến xa tôi cảm thấy hệ nho đơn nghe nhiều ông chọn
ngày này thì tôi bảo có nhiều lý do có thể hiểu do là
nó nói thằng là do kinh tế Chẳng hạn chẳng qua là tao kinh tế là chẳng qua
tao học được mỗi ngày nè tạo thế này tao đam mê gì thì như tội nó đấy thì vẫn khó
tính xa không Ừ ông vẫn Giỏi cái gì ở thực sự rất là giỏi với nó thì ông ông
phải đam mê thật thì dùng từ đam mê thật bởi vì à Ví dụ điển hình nhé Nếu tôi bảo
rồi có rất nhiều âm trẻ coder sau bảy tám năm kinh nghiệm sau bảy tám năm làm
anh Bởi vì ông ấy cái gì quanh quản lý làm lại những cái thứ anh ấy đã biết
không đam mê không đọc thêm tài liệu không không mày ông không trao dồi thêm
kiến thức bởi vì kín vì công nghệ này nó sẽ thay đổi theo thời gian mỗi năm phát
minh là một cái gì mới trong cái ngày này xong rồi ông không tận dụng nó không
biết được nó là cái gì kìa cốt của ông sẽ vẫn Chị cứ thế mà thằng khác thì cốt
1 tô đơn ông tôi luôn Ông vẫn đúng không Thì làm xong tiền ra bằng nó có thể nói
chỉ cần 1 năm kinh nghiệm nó làm ngon lành hơn ông 785 cắm đầu vào cốc đúng
mỗi vài cái nhẫn như điều Ông chỉ biết cốc mũ cây trong biết bán hàng ở trong
cái tin tức ông không biết cốt thêm cái gì Ông ông nghĩ thế đủ rồi em ạ Nhớ trả
lương sẽ thấp hơn cái thằng mà cốt được những cái trang to hơn thế thôi
à à Nên chọn công ty thế nào thì như tôi vừa nói thì công ty xe grab thì mình sẽ
làm được khá nhiều việc cũng như ông học hỏi được nhiều từ chính các sếp bởi có
sếp phải giỏi mỗi giám khảo sát nó sẽ họp vào đấy rất nhiều từ chính các sẽ
chứ không phải chưa Giờ biết mặt mũi sẽ là là ai cần thế nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ
nhược điểm là không phải tự học khá nhiều phù hợp với ông nào có thực sự là
gọi trí anh Bởi vì lên đấy năm chỉ có ai kèm Âu
nhưng mà ông nói chút ông sẽ được gặp chính những anh mà về sau sẽ làm leader
đây là anh để sẽ rất là giỏi nữa đúng không còn đi sát thì thường là toàn
những người giỏi mới ngồi làm toàn người dốt những người cùng làm thì cũng chết à
Nhưng mà Thì sẽ học được còn hơn là công ty lớn thì ông mới vào thì phù hợp với
việc là họ sẽ là chuyên nghiệp cái thứ Thời gian cứ thử nói chung và mọi thứ
văn phòng Mọi thứ cơ sở rất đau buồn thôi nhưng bù lại thì ông cảm thấy
tôi cả nhân tôi thì đang thiên về bên Pháp này là thằng nhà tôi sẽ nói hơi
tiêu cực một tí ở bên con tim lớn khi mà mới thực tập kẹo
Ừ ông sẽ không cảm thấy ông quan trọng ông nghỉ được phải tương tự như thế rồi
kìa kiểu họ họ có 100 thằng như ông nên anh đâu Không có Trọng này ra là cái ông
không tính nói lắm Ông lên muộn hãy lên sớm họ chẳng quan trọng cũng là nó họ
Trần Công rồi trừ tiền ông rồi ra ông không quan trọng với họ đúng không Thằng
cha nó khỏi bị tiêu cực thể dùng từ tiêu cực như thế à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi bảo với ông Nếu em thích
môi trường chuyên nghiệp không làm việc trong các thứ chữ nhiệt có đầy đủ tất cả
thứ rồi có chồng làm thì công ty lớn sẽ
đào tạo ông như thế con thường mà tôi vẫn động viên mọi người là nên khi mà
mới đi tập thì nên vào công ty bé họ được nhiều sau đó thì về xong muốn ổn
định thì Và cũng tin lớn thế thôi
anh làm sao để biết quét đào tạo bằng cốt Z cách đơn giản thôi ẩn cano xem mấy
cái Block in Lào Cai đôi khi nó có thẳng vào chữ vazquez rồi đấy và những và pin
rồi em tra thêm tên blog in ra thôi Thực ra có sẵn tiện ích để mà biết được kể
trong cái thưởng nó có thể sử dụng muốn có thể sử dụng công nghệ 2 ngôn ngữ gì
cũng có cái tiện ích đấy à à tiếp theo nên sửa được tủ lạnh điều
hòa bình có bình ắc quy hỏng không về đến nhà hợp lập trình sẽ người ông
không hề biết mày cái về cái này có sờ được không đúng không ạ
Em cứ hỏi lại muốn khẳng định lại một lần nữa đã Nhưng mà sửa wi-fi cài lại
Win mấy ông cũng không được học nhưng mà tôi phiền mấy ông vẫn mới biết qua về
những cái này không là hạt nở biết sự wi-fi như nói cho nó biết cài đặt cấu
hình cái gì đó cũng nhờ cài lại Win Hay là tối ưu máy máy chạy nhanh hơn nữa Vân
biết được rồi cái phần mềm mà nó dạy biết được tránh kiểu tránh virus tráng
men que gì đó là những cái thứ mà tối thiểu của dẫn công nghệ cầm nên biết để
mà kiểu tự bảo vệ vẫn mình tự bảo vệ mình phải tự như thế
về tự nhiên dân công nghệ so với kiểu đưa nghe có thể mang mày ra hàng thì
không đi sửa lại nhưng mà ngoài ra thôi Anh chẳng nói chơi bay được đấy nhưng mà
không biết được nó sửa cái gì của mình nó chém giá lên rồi Nó cố tình phá của
mình Mình không biết Nó ăn cắp dữ liệu máy mình mình không biết
Không chỉ thế thì hơi giờ Ẩm Thực ra là cái đấy là người dùng nào
cũng nên biết thì đừng nói việc ở Dân công nghệ dùng từ như thế nhờ Ok thì bây
giờ người dùng thì cảm thấy công nghệ bây giờ cái gì đó qua cái gớm rồi người
ta cũng đi tra Google độ người ta lo ngại tra Google Thì ra mình biết cách ra
gồm à Ngon Ninjago cái là ra có đầy mà nho mình phải tra và làm được những cái
đấy tao Nghĩa hết
a tiếp theo lương ngành này nghìn đô Ừ vợ thật được không Tôi đã nói rồi có
rất nhiều cố tơ thế Mày lập trình viên không phải đưa Pearl mà coder là người
biết rõ lại Cốc giống như thư ký ngồi mỗi Võ Văn bản đấy thì lương của họ sẽ
có nhất được nhưng thấy triệu họ thường lại không phấn đấu hơn và họ ăn an phận
mới được ấy thì ra là kiểu họ vẫn nhìn mấy ông mấy em mới vào xong rồi em đấy
làm những nửa tháng mở lên đấy lương nghìn đô vẫn là một thần tượng bạn còn
bạn còn nhà người ta khi con à lương này nhìn Đô hai chục
nghìn đô đó chuyện bình thường kể cả Ở trong nước thì đừng nói nước ngoài nước
ngoài thì họ trả đường ra ổn hơn rồi A và không hẳn với mức đến nỗi thần
thánh khó khăn đến thế bởi vì a Ừ cái á Em nói như nào nhỉ số người được như thế
cũng nhiều ý nghĩa ông phải công nhận là nó nhiều
chứ không phải là kiểu vì nó không phải là cái gì đó kiểu ưu tú
chỉ có 12 người yêu hàng nghìn người không không không như thế
Tôi nghĩ là tỷ lệ đó vẫn phải là em định đi nô nhá vài nghìn thôi nhé tỉ lệ dân
nhau cái ngày này lương nghìn đô Tôi nghĩ sẵn ở trên 10 phần trăm ít nhất ở
trên trán trên 10 phần trăm bạn chị ạ 20 30 nó không dám chém nhưng mà số người
ta quen thì 3 - mấy ông sinh viên Tôi không nói
nhưng mà số người mà bằng tuổi tôi hơn thì hơn 50 phần trăm bạn thôi đường trên
Windows theo này này
dữ liệu có thể được lương nghìn đô như họ thì tôi vừa nói đây nghe Ăn gì ở cậu
Họ không phải là cái gì đó Kiểu gì đó có
ghê gớm hả nên hoàn toàn được ô tô hiện tại lương chơi được nghìn đô
mình có thể mời chê thôi nhờ tôi nhảy sang công ty khác thì chắc chắn tôi đưa
1.000 đô thật hoặc là tôi một phần là tôi bảo tôi đưa lương cũng chẳng Điều gì
đã tôi lương từ 15 triệu xong nó cứ 6 tháng tôi được tăng lương 2 triệu một
lần sẽ toàn bảo là em em em thấy ổn không Dạ vâng em hoàn toàn hội rồi thoải
mái chị anh không tăng lương em được nên hai ra luôn nó chị liên hệ Hiện Thực
ra tôi vẫn thèm nổ hơn vì tôi riêng tội đưa Kiên một đống nghiệp
anh cũng khá quan trọng ấy phải để tôi đang làm khá như thế nào quan trọng công
ty cảm thế kiểu không thể để mất tôi vậy thôi Nghị Phát không biết có ông nào dám
động vào cái đống Tôi đang ngồi lắm bởi vì nó rất là đau đầu cũng là toàn những
tính năng quan trọng từ nói chung là tôi khẳng định ở tôi đang
có tầm ảnh hưởng khá lớn nhưng mà Đấy lượng của tôi đang đang dần địa thấp
Mỹ Tâm Nhất à thống nhất trong Đảng trong anh em làm
em cho tôi bảo tuần bảo rồi Tôi hơi bị tự nhiên một tí nhỏ tôi quan trọng tôi
biết được mình đang ở đang ở tầm nào biết Mày biết tao đúng không đấy à nhầm
biết định bita và bị nghiệm tử thi anh em thành ra là kéo Tôi chỉ cần được
cái sự tôn trọng thôi chứ tôi không muốn trọng về tiền bạc B lắm ngày sau lập gia
đình hay về sau tôi Mở công mở quán cà phê thì sao Lúc đấy cần vốn thật à
Em làm thế nào để gặp vấn đề chán nản bất mãn khi mà làm ngày này hay tôi cảm
thấy áp dụng với cả từ trong cuộc sống được đó là nếu đừng nghĩ nó nữa trong
thời gian đấy mấy ông chẳng làm cái gì đâu người ông đừng ngồi cốt nữa Khi mà
kiểu ông chán hay ông video ngồi chơi cọ cho mình một ngày nghỉ đi 12 2000 được
bởi vì lúc này ông làm gì thì cũng chỉ hỏng thôi Hãy dùng tự như hệ nên là hãy
thoải mái thoải mãi được ngồi làm việc từ con Nếu là sự ông ông thoải mái ở
nhưng mà khi ông đến thì ông làm việc với ông nạn đấy nó bỏ luôn cái việc đi
Thế chịu Ừ ok ờ
I burn 60 rồi các nhóm bắt đầu nha khi bắt đầu thôi như tôi nói đấy thì cái
á kênh cái kênh của anh ạ đợi tôi nói nốt những cái nghe này vừa nãy kênh Hạnh
Phạm power của mỹ phẩm đây là người nghèo rồi
mấy ông thế anh ấy chửi bậy khá nhiều nhưng mà nhưng mà nếu như mấy ông cha
giờ tôi nếu mà bình thường Nhiều âm xem mấy cái video vừa nãy thấy trị bệnh
nhiều như thế mày không sẽ nghĩa kênh này sẽ là toàn kiểu kiểu hơi mất dạy như
ý và kiểu Chánh kiến thức gì ở không nhìn qua cách nói chuyện tôi thấy cách
nói chuyện anh đấy ổn hôm nay là tôi vẫn tìm cảnh đấy là xem
được mày cái video Anh ấy nói về lịch sử này hay phết tôi xem mấy cái Gần đây tôi
đưa nhau Tôi không xem hết mấy cái video nhảy vì về các bạn nó vẫn là mỹ thuật
hay về cái gì ở tôi không quan tâm nhưng mấy ông xem mấy cái gần đây về lịch sử
Anh ấy nói đúng kiểu cách nói chuyện của anh đấy rất phù hợp với nói để mà làm
cái một thứ mà có thể nhằm giảm như này thành một cái thứ
A2 gì để mà nhiều người tiếp cận nơi cơ bản
để tội thích thì sự nó xem cái này còn cuốn hơn tôi muốn chia sẻ với ông nữa
Ừ Ok bây giờ bắt đầu chuyện đó nhỉ à ừ ừ
ừ ừ Ừ anh có Facebook không thì ông ở
Facebook gì Facebook tôi thì đừng Nhà tôi có dùng Facebook
Anh đoán thử lương ông tôi đi cô giáo tôi nhớ một lần nữa từng chia sẻ hồi nãy
anh ấy ở biển xinh cho xem cái vóc như anh ấy trên 2.000 được vậy Nhưng mà thực
ra thì tôi không quan tâm lương tôi không quan
tâm tiền bạc mà thì nên làm nếu hỏi tôi cái đấy tao cũng chẳng nghĩ đến đâu ạ
cha mẹ ông bà thôi cả nhóm rồi nhóm 1 đây
tôi ghim và nhỏ ma hay nhóm 2 rồi có mặt ai chưa
ừ ừ
Ở nhóm 2 ơi Hưng và kiều tranh
Ở lần cuối nhắn tin là từ tháng 10 biết bây giờ
anh không biết bây giờ nào
sơ đồ án làm web bán hàng như này có đợt tham khảo video
cho các bạn tham khảo mọi thứ thoải mái mà tham khảo thôi đừng có cốt về 10 cái
tôi tôi sẽ có hỏi và nhóm khi mà tố hướng này làm tôi thể bảo một nhóm đó Mở
cốc lên và thử nói xem đoạn đấy mà nói vấn đề gì đấy Nếu không trả được thì thì
tách bởi vì rõ là mà ông phải hiểu không đã làm những gì đúng không đấy
Ừ cái này ra mày đừng có khó lắm không phải giao diện nhé Nó hỏi về à
em về tính năng mà ông đã làm đấy
ở đâu nhóm hay mất tích rồi ở nhóm 16 Vậy mấy nhóm 20 lần lượt nhé
Đúng không nhóm ma mà kiểu không được bỏ qua luôn
an ninh - hôm hôm nay không không thể bảo vệ hết rồi Cả nhóm về đâu tranh thủ
nhóm nào bảo vệ được thì bảo vệ trước Ừ nó 16 ngõ 11 các nhóm đâu rồi
anh alo alo
à à à à
ở nhóm 11 lại nghỉ rồi vậy
cho hs làm mà không chơi game mình dậy Tôi
bảo ở chơi game thì coi chừng bệnh được nhưng mà đợi nhau tùy thôi Chỉ không
thích mấy ông chơi cùng tôi không phải chữa bệnh mà mày ông ấy cho cùng là đập
phá Dỗi rồi Bỏ game rồi nạt à Cái thứ tôi không biết rồi đấy chơi game mà phải
có tinh thần đồng đội tôi con điểm như thế còn chửi trời thì tôi sẵn Hoàn chổi
mấy thằng bạn nữa nói rằng một tinh thần đồng đội đi chơi game mà phải tin nhưng
nó không bị chơi thử cái máy chơi với anh em không tin nhưng nồng độ
với
ở nhà ông kêu vẫn ngồi cô thêm à Ừ anh cũng chơi game à Thế bây giờ rồi
Đã số dẫn công nghệ yêu kia từ chơi game mà là người đam mê dùng máy tính mà
ở
nhóm 22 xin bảo vệ đợt 2 Ok anh cũng cũng gần quấy em ạ nhóm nhóm đi
rồi 2 16 11 rồi
Ê mày nhóm nghỉ rồi Đang có tận năm mấy ông mà chứng tỏ năm mấy ông này đã ngồi
treo có nhóm mà nó có mặt đầy đủ đây không nhỉ
Ê thằng bờ tôi không trả lời mày đã mấy ông bạn Toyota là tôi chơi Zalo chat tôi
chưa nhấn phận thôi
chị Hà không lỡ lời cho arum mất não chẳng cần tránh thoát gì cả à
ở đâu rồi Alo mình đâu hết rồi
hai nhóm nhóm 16 không có đây đúng không 35 11 thì xin nghỉ cái gì đâu ạ
ạ Bạn ấy làm một mình là 11 bạn này là một mình đã làm gần xong rồi nhớ bạn ơi
bà bận thôi ờ ờ
à à Ở
nhóm 2 mất tích đúng không Ok nhóm 16 mất tích nốt đúng không
từ nhỏ mà
ở nhóm 18 vậy 58 có đây không
ừ ừ
ở nhóm 18 tháng ba 25
Khi bữa mày đồng nghĩa với tâm sự thôi à Không
đâu hết rồi không bảo vệ thử thì khi thiệp mấy ông ấy mới hôm thứ bảy bảo
vệ thật rồi đấy mọi bảo vệ thật mà tôi gọi cũng kiểu như này tội bỏ qua luôn
đấy anh cái để nhóm bà heo con em làm cái gì sao ạ
em à Ok Yamaha không Ừ cũng được được đúng ạ ạ
ờ ờ phần mềm gì ở đó thời gian đã qua ca Qua ca Than gì vậy ạ
ông ngoại thằng đấy màn hình của em bây giờ thấy
anh thấy màn hình của em kìa em thấy thấy thế giới thế thôi I
ở
nhóm của bọn em thì làm về Shop Thời Trang resort cho anh ấy Nam Long hướng
dẫn lắm em gồm Em tên là Nguyễn Huy Hùng làm
phần quản lý và bạn bù việc làm bên Cần khách hàng
lý do chọn đề tài thì để bắt kịp với xu hướng 4.0 mà thời đại
dịch bệnh Mọi người Đổ xô đi mua sắm online là phần lớn và đề phổ biến nghe
một shop vào đó lên internet và bọn em làm dự án này để học hỏi thêm nhiều kỹ
năng mới các đối tượng sử dụng người dùng có
khách vãng lai và cách đăng ký nhân viên và quản lý
so với phần khách vãng lai thì có thể xem tất cả sản phẩm trong chi
tiết sản phẩm và đăng nhập đăng ký có còn khách đăng ký thì có các chức năng
của khách mắt lai có trên tăng xuất đặt hàng cửa hàng và chúc đặt hàng thì có
tên người nhận và địa chỉ người nhận phần nhân viên thì ông không thể tạo tài
khoản và chỉ có thể đăng nhập đăng xuất quản
lý sản phẩm và quản lý hóa đơn về còn quản lý thì quản lý các nhân viên
của có các quyền của nhân viên quản lý nhân viên và quản lý nhà sản xuất
cho bọn em hiểu công nghệ FPT 7.4 css3 html5 JavaScript và máy SQL
cho tôi đâu thực thể thì
khách hàng thì người ta đặt của gì sinh ra nhiều chi
tiết hóa đơn không nhân viên à chi tiết Hóa đơn này sẽ được một nhân viên
100 viên diệt để để sinh ra một hóa đơn cái đoạn này số thể sai đấy không phải
chi tiết Hóa đơn đó bị nhầm ý là chi tiết cho order cheap
order từ sai rồi chi tiết hóa đơn không phải chụp thể đó là cái thuật chi tiết
hóa đơn nó sinh ra giữa mối quan hệ giữa hóa đơn và những sản phẩm thôi Đây là nó
không phải tập thể Anh Vàng Anh xem bỏ qua đi lại sang nha
Tiếp theo sở sửa cái này nhá vào Vậy à Ừ cái này do là không vận dụng cái
khoảng không em nhìn trông ảnh hơi vỡ nhỉ
à Tại em chả biết rồi em không dùng bao coi không chia lắm ý
á hậu không có gì để đổi lại cái đổi lại cái kiểu khác đấy Nhìn ảnh ở rõ hơn Ok
em thử nói đi anh
ở đây thì nhà sản xuất sẽ
là khó ngoài của sản phẩm và
sản phẩm thì chúng ta sẽ từ sản phẩm Khuyến địt chi tiết order và
từ order sẽ nói rằng à
300 em không cần phải nói theo kiểu đấy Em nói theo kiểu là ờ
ở đầu tiên là khách hàng đầu tiên là có những cái gì trước này một tí à của
Admin này có có nhà sản xuất này đúng không Nhà sản xuất thì có nhiều sản phẩm
nên là sẽ nổi bạn sản phẩm tiếp theo là khách hàng lúc đầu đăng ký vào sẽ lưu
vào bạc khách hàng này rồi khách hàng đặt đặt hàng mình sẽ lưu
vào đâu thông qua cái gì đấy Nó quy trình để khi mà Vào vào trang web sẽ làm
những gì thì từ đấy mẹ sinh ra những bảng nào ấy thì không
thì bây giờ khách hàng đặt hàng khách hàng đăng ký thị xã công ty chất vào
bảng tầm mây của khách hàng đăng ký khách hàng đặt hàng thì sẽ có chi tiết
order mà đi khách hàng ấn ấn đặt hàng thì sẽ
dữ liệu sẽ được đổ học bên nó bảng order sinh nhân viên diệt bảng A nữ diễn viên
Việt order sẽ được đổ vào bảng hóa đơn hả Sao lại có
Em à em muốn lưu lại có nhân viên nào đã diệt port nào đúng
không Dạ vâng ạ Ừ thế thì chỉ còn thêm một cột ở trong
họ bảo ừ Hay là em muốn lưu lại là lịch sử là từ trưa mai là kiểu thằng này đã
thay đổi tình trạng gì nhỉ Hay như nào vì anh thấy à Nếu mà em muốn
làm thế thì phải bạn phải cuộc xát ớt nữa cũng phải lên phải lưu lại cho bạn
kia là mới đúng
ở cái đoạn này là do là em chưa chưa chưa hiểu về cách tạo
cơ sở liệu rồi Nghĩa Đàn Em thì chỉ đang buồn nó cả lưu lại là người nào đã duyệt
cả đơn nào đúng không vào thị thi cái việc đấy là có thể lưu lại ở trong chính
bảng order cũng được nếu mà buồn lưu theo cậu là một người thì giật 11
à à Nhập một đơn chỉ được dệt bởi một người thì thì em lưu lại vào trong bảo
order là được còn nếu mà em muốn lưu theo kiểu là một đơn có thể được thay
đổi trạng thái bởi nhiều người thì sẽ tách riêng ra 1 bảng trung gian để mà
lưu lại mã đơn này tình trạng đơn này bà mã của cái người duyệt đấy còn bây giờ
em em muốn lưu bản chắc em chuyển một lưu là thành thằng duyệt đơn này thôi và
đơn chị được diệt một lần thôi chẳng hạn đúng không và thì lưu lại mã của của
admin ở trong bảng order được rồi Xin
chào em Em nhìn lại cũng thấy hơi sai sai em cũng bảo vệ cùng nhóm mà thấy lẽ
ra đi bỏ cái bỏ cái hóa đơn thì vào trong cái cả đời luôn
cái cái thôi Các là sửa bây giờ có không biết có kỳ âm chạm nhanh thôi đoạn này
sửa anh Nghĩa làm nhanh thôi mà khi các sở đoạn này Lúc đầu Lúc đầu mà
chưa được duyệt thì nó có thể lúc đầu mà mới tạo đơn đấy mà mã pin có thể để
chống nhé bởi vì lúc tạ đơn thì đã có ai duyệt đâu đúng không sẽ để nó luôn đấy
và nghe được mà phần PowerPoint của em mà hết thời bây
giờ đến bạn Bùi Việt sẽ cái mô Bên khách hàng à
anh em cho anh và các bạn ạ
anh ạ tất
cả mọi nhìn thấy Oanh Thành thấy rõ ạ ok rồi
trang web của em là gồm trang chính là trang khi chưa đăng nhập thì sẽ hiển thị
được trang chủ ở phần phần thông tin về cửa hàng có thể xem
được sản phẩm và có thể xem được phần liên hệ với chúng tôi thì Phân sản phẩm
thì cái khác nữa sẵn sản phẩm là có những sản phẩm gì nhưng mà sẽ không thể
sẽ không thể thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng được thì
sẽ vào phần đăng nhập đăng nhập từ xa có đăng ký thì chúng ta phải đăng ký gồm có
đăng ký sẽ có Violet cấp kiểu thì là nếu mà nhập một thì sẽ tên đăng ký đăng nhập
không đúng
và nếu mặt chưa Ông Nếu mà chưa nhập thì sẽ
hiển thị là tên đăng nhập không được để trống
khi nhập đầy đủ thì sẽ hiển thị được nhé em sẽ đăng ký tài khoản
có số điện thoại thì sẽ đăng ký được bằng 10 số và đăng ký bằng số điện thoại
của người Việt Nam nhưng kể đã 0372 là 057 người đó
Email thì nếu mà nhập một ký tự Khác phần Email
thì nó sẽ hiển thị là email không đúng hoặc đã nếu mà không nhập Thì sẽ hiện
đại email không được để trống Còn nếu mà ghi đầy đủ thì sẽ lưu được và chuyển
sang phần khác mật khẩu thì sẽ là Hiển thị được 10 ký tự và phải có chữ thường
chữ in hoa và số vào một cái đặc biệt thì em nhập là 123456 a b c d và hỏi
chấm nếu sẽ qua phần này và sang phần khác này em nhập lại như vừa nãy
thì sẽ đăng nhập được đăng kí tài khoản ở chuyển đến Ông Hiển thị được chào mừng
bạn đã quay trở lại ờ sau khi đang cần đăng đăng nhập được
xong thì sẽ đang xuất alo alo alo alo anh hỏi tí
Alo anh hỏi tí em Em nghe thấy ông không có
ừ em em chưa chỉnh bên đăng ký xịn quá vậy anh hỏi tí về cái đăng ký được không
a wi-fi quay lại đi đăng ký Em vừa bảo kiểm tra Email nhập
hợp lại bây giờ sự anh nhập một cái email không tồn tại có kiểm tra được
Em email không tưởng đại ở nhà mình liên lạc không ạ Không này tra đúng
không Hết rồi bảo đấy Nhập nhập mật khẩu thì cũng để kiểm tra mật khẩu mạng đúng
không Thế mới phải yêu cầu nhập nhiều khí tự các thứ tư đúng không thử thứ
nhất là cái tra thì cái cái cái này Anh hiểu Nhưng mà cái
nhược điểm là em không hiển thị ra cho người dùng để người dùng biết được à Lúc
đầu vậy nên nhập ngào thư ai là thế Bây giờ anh thử nhập mật khẩu giống hệt Cái
Email thì có được nhiều trang web từ hôm trọ
nhập kiểu khi cài nhập mật khẩu giống hệt email
được nhiều trang web sẽ không cho nhập mật
khẩu kiểu dạng là có tên mình anh đấy hoặc còn tình mail em nên biết vụ này
không phải được a khái niệm dự chỉ làm như nào
Ừ thế thì tài chính còn nói đấy nữa ừ Ừ ok đấy Vâng chất cho tìm hiểu được quá
nhiều về phần đấy ạ hả Không Anh hỏi thế thôi hỏi và đôi khi anh hỏi những cái
câu thử hỏi mẹo móc móc một tí ở xem nếu mà em trả lời được thì được cộng thêm
điểm nỗi buồn không không mấy cái ca không quan
trọng lắm nghe là thử cái em không cần lại để lâu sau quá như Ừ thì em nói qua
làm được một cái này thì để mô cũng được nhưng mà bây giờ mình trong cách bán
hàng mà tập trung ở bên bán hàng ngày nhảy sang Quỳnh năng bán hàng Ừ
vợ Thế em tiếp tục là phần đăng nhập thì sẽ nhập mà những người thông tin là mình
vừa nhập thì em mới nhập tài khoản thế này mật khẩu à
có đầy đủ ký tự như mình anh vừa nhập thì sẽ có làm gì nữa không nhập kho lần
đăng nhập tiếp theo thì khi mà em tắt web đi rồi để
anh tự chắc tài khoản tại website Ừ thì em xin được một tài khoản trước đó
có thì em được không ạ ừ ừ
ừ ừ
à à ở
nhà ấy bước tên tài khoản Anh chờ một chút để em bé mật khẩu thử thử nhập
ejection em có bị ông Hai em kiểm tra rồi
em vẫn chưa thử ở thì em vẫn mất tình ép kéo riesen anh thấy đau em phần Xperia S
nó hỏi thì giấu giấu
giấu chuối nấu chuối Anh ở Dậu
đấu nhảy đơn nháy đơn nhảy đơn soi cách ra
không khó không nháy đơn khỏi nhớ đôi nhảy đơn cách là o1 bằng một
o00o alturas [âm nhạc]
Ừ rồi Oro ordro đấy Một Bảng 1
à Xong rồi Thăng a Limit 15 được nó gọi đi 1 nữa cho chắc
không không không lý 11 trước ở cái Thăng
3 cách phải dùng dấu cách ra không mà lỗi đấy cách của lý một cách cách chữa
lý một ở cách cả chỗ một bằng một lá Ừ cái đúng rồi
Ê thằng gọi không chữ Limit một cũng phải cách ra chứ
Ừ cái đúng rồi Đâu có đâu đâu rồi Chạy thử đi ạ
Ừ đợi không được vợ tất cả tội không biết được là ông cốt
như thế nào không được đấy ạ cho anh xem cho em số tài khoản không
biết được vài biết ở đây chưa
anh ạ ừ ừ
à à
ừ ừ ừ ừ
à à số miền Bắc
Chứ không lẽ sử dụng vào tài khoản đã được nhận trước
sau khi đăng nhập xong thì nó sẽ hiển thị bản thông báo chào mừng nào quay trở
lại thì ấn vào giỏ hàng thì nó sẽ hiển thị chưa có sản phẩm Vì mình chưa tin
trong giỏ hàng thì sao Lúc đấy thì ta sẽ đi thêm sản
phẩm vào và ấn vào thêm vào giỏ hàng sẽ hiện ra một thông báo đã thêm vào giỏ
hàng sẽ có một giờ hàng ở trong
trong danh ở trong giỏ hàng có thể thêm số lượng giảm số lượng và xóa sản phẩm
Sau khi xóa xong thì sẽ hiển thị chưa có sản phẩm trong giỏ hàng
em bắt đầu đấy ăn ngon thử mua hàng thì nó sẽ có hiển thị là thông tin của người
đã đăng ký tài khoản có thể chỉnh sửa được thông tin này và cao kiện là hàng
thì sẽ hiển thị là hàng thành công
Khi bữa sau đây là thành điểm mua em ạ Con
phân quản lý đơn hàng thì bọn anh cũng chưa chưa hiển thị bên ngoài bao giờ nó
chưa làm xong cái phần đấy ạ sẽ hiển thị ở bên phần của Admin
Ok em ok sẽ bạn kia thứ để một à à
số trang bạc lắc
nói thay gì nên anh nghĩ mà tình em sẽ ok rồi
Đây là phần demo của bên amin thì nó vẫn dùng một tài khoản đã được cấp trước
có gì đây là mẹ và một em cũng chưa nào Thống kê đâu
bên này thêm thêm nhân viên Cái này là quản lý nhân viên quản lý sản phẩm nữ
anh quản lí nhân viên quản lý sản phẩm quản lý sản xuất mới cả hóa đơn thì
bên quản lý hóa đơn thì anh có hóa đơn em mới thêm vào từ bữa nay ít thì giống
và ấn Việt thì nó sẽ nhảy xuống đây chứ em à
có thêm chẳng biết trình bày ạ
em à ok ừ ừ anh ấy nhìn qua anh thấy rồi ok làm đầy đủ được các tỉnh năm nữa tìm
kiếm thân Trang anh anh thích ở bên em ở một điểm này đó là kẹo hiển thị ra thêm
sắc thêm luôn ở trên trên luôn cái phần trang danh sách cũng khá là hay để thêm
nhanh đúng không những nhược điểm nhược điểm với cấp bậc về đó em phải để nó sẽ
lấy often hoa cà radio thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn để người dùng nhập số anh nghĩ là
đấy và đấy À tất cả là em nên ưu tiên với văn hóa đơn
lên trên có hôm trước có hai nhóm bị dính cái vụ này kiểu máy lu của Thường
mới vào ý tưởng anh nhìn cái đầu tiên là nhìn cái hóa đơn rồi người ta làm việc
hóa đơn nhiều nhất này sau đó sản phẩm nhân viên thì đây Superman hãy ăn mì đi
nghỉ superman superman để ý của anh nhìn anh hơi hiểu
nhầm tí thì thì đấy thì người ta sẽ ưu tiên những cái quan trọng kia lên trên
đúng không Rồi chắc là nhóm em mới kiểu mới làm xong về
vụ hóa đơn đúng nhỉ bờ thấy giao diện vừa rồi còn mất cái Menu nhé
anh Na menu menu ở đâu À nó xem chết đi ở đây vẫn vẫn có đâu mất cái Menu rồi
đấy à ba lô
của bên tải đâu bên trái rồi mất hết rồi nữa do Dị cái gì
à à à à Cái này em làm sao xài chứ
em cũng đang vẫn đang bận với trường quá thì có gì bổ sung cái này qua bên khách
hàng được nhanh mà nó ôm ôm đúng cái này so với khách hàng là xong và ok nhóm em
còn hết tính năng gì muốn trình bày được nghỉ không dám em cái gì gọi hoàn thiện
cố gắng hoàn thiện thực sự hoàn thiện phần thêm sửa xóa xem đó à Ok Ok cảm ơn
em nhé Anh có đây
nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ nhóm 18 rồi Anh hello
Ừ Ok em em làm một mình hả hay làm hai người nhỉ
Lại rất là người muốn bảo sao ok chuyện đâu
em ạ trò
chuyện chia sẻ màn hình đi
cho mọi người đến với đi Alo có ai thấy à
ok ok rồi Em để cho mọi người đến với bài thuyết
trình về đồ án nhóm 18 có một thành viên Đoàn Nguyễn Huy thành viên còn lại không
thấy
nó sẽ được về đồ án thì đây là độ án được thiết kế sau khóa học lập trình web
cơ bản đồ ăn sử đi xe Vespa JavaScript es6
sb700 42 cực hệ quản trị cơ sở dữ liệu mysql 5.7.3 3
vấn đề hiện tại là tiểu hạn chưa đưa vào hoạt động nhưng
vẫn mong muốn của chủ cửa hàng là nâng cao trải nghiệm mua sắm của khách hàng
và phương thức quản lý của vấn đề của nhân viên nên dự án được ra đều
về yêu cầu chức năng khách hàng chưa có tài khoản thì có đăng kí xem tất cả sản
phẩm và tìm kiếm khách hàng đã có tài khoản thì đăng nhập tìm kiếm Xem tất cả
sản phẩm đặt hàng chuyển sang tin cá nhân đổi mật khẩu và xem lại các đơn
hàng về nhân viên của hẹn thì có đăng nhập
tìm kiếm xem sửa tất cả sản phẩm Xem sự tích ở nhà sản xuất Xem tất cả đơn hàng
và giữa các đơn Hoàng đang chờ bọn admin thì
giống với nhân viên nhưng có thêm là xem thêm sửa anh đi lên Biên xóa sản phẩm
sáng nhà sản xuất và thay đổi tình trạng cả đơn hàng
lịch sử sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu của giống
như mọi người thấy nó là bạn thay nó sẽ không nói với bạn rồi đó
Tại rồi đắm say em lưu là và chè để lưu được nhiều rồi Rất thai
lưu được nhiều ít hay đi vào trong cái vào rất sai đó
ai không cách IDM vào đất để 350 để lưu được nhiều cái thai AD bản thay
thế là không đúng đúng lắm để nguyên tắc của cơ sở lý ở nhỉ
So sánh Đáng lẽ ở lên tạo ra bạn sung gian đúng
Xin chào bạn chúng ta Đây đúng lưu lại code hay để mà nối ID của Thái thằng đấy
Ừ thế thôi không xa Okay tiếp theo
a
Token ở đây là cái Cookie
bản pháp và vú sờ có sẽ có Token Token đó là cu ki còn
bạn điêu nối với beauty Hair không và ngoại qua
BIDV cái card Viettel đi được lưu sai xin nó sẽ có
giãn Tây Sơn ở trong sẽ có ID của rồi đất ID size Sẽ Về Man City là số lượng
của sản phẩm cũng cái bill đó status ở đây em sẽ lưu theo 3 dạng có
sẵn là để đang đợi để duyệt và Đảng ủy à
Ừ ok đấy ảnh em vừa nói là cái parte lưu lại
cái gì nhỉ nốt đi xô là lưu lại phù rất ID và
tôi rất size hồ bơi cay what I Anh bận chút tí nó sẽ không có trong đây
Đấy nó sẽ do khách hàng đặt nó được lưu vào trong phiên giỏ hàng rõ khi nhỏ hè
sẽ được đẩy vào trong rồi đắp Viettel cái này nhớ thanh toán thì sẽ được đã
yêu rồi lấy đi theo đó không thực ra thể hơi sai đấy Tại sao không tách riêng là
các cụ ghi âm nghỉ mà mình lưu lại trong một câu làm gì
xe nôi truy vấn một lần không lấy một là cục 01 mày thì em nói sao khó hơn là một
nếu mày một lối ra phố tắc để lấy thông tin vô đắt cũng như là vì sao không
thống kê được thống kê nó khó đúng không em em nên
tách là các cột cái cái cái phù hợp khi mãi lưu lại dạ mà chuỗi hay dặn zishan
để mà em như loại ốc sên của biuret Thích thì anh còn hiểu được nếu trong
trường hợp mà em đưa lại à trong đấy Kiểu size color hay bất kỳ cái thông tin
khác của của đắt để muốn lưu lại để mà biết được đơn đấy đã đặt những gì thì
còn chấp nhận được nhưng mà còn những cái mà lại có thể nói ra mảng khác hay
để thống kê như thế giống như là codec đi hai à hay là con thấy chi được ra rồi
đấy không không nên lưu lại vào trong một cột như thế vì à Có sao không không
thống kê không nối được bạn đúng không ở đây là em tắt ra đợi đấy vì hơn
được cái xa tốt ở phố đắt retail nó là để làm gì hả em vừa nói là để lưu cái gì
nhỉ Lưu trạng thái thì chị sẽ đến là đang chờ đã duyệt và xã hội thì nếu mà
chỉ ngồi ba cái thì anh nghĩa là lưu lại số xong rồi định nghĩa nó thủ công thì
nó hợp lý hơn nó nhẹ đúng không Mà đã là lưu lại Tại sao không lưu vào trong hóa
đơn mà lại lưu ở trong hóa đơn chi tiết nhỉ à
ờ ờ
Ừ cái cái cái này thì ra hôm hôm qua có
một nhóm bị dính cái này nó chỉ phù hợp với trường hợp là giờ sự là em muốn
duyệt từng sản phẩm của một Đôn ví dụ Giả sử là sản phẩm này hết hàng rồi thì
em mà em không duyệt cái sản phẩm đấy nhưng còn sản phẩm khác còn hàng thì em
vẫn duyệt nghĩa trong một đơn có có sản phẩm bị hủy có sản phẩm không bị hủy thì
chấp nhận được còn nếu mà em cả đơn của em chỉ có
một là em xử lý cả đơn hay là em không cách vẽ đơn nó được lưu vào bất đi bộ cơ
đốc đi theo này nó lưu hết vào trong đây thì đây tớ đặt ở đó là nó nguyên cả cái
bi luôn không không không không em Bill cả bưu là gái kia chứ em biết Viettel là
là một điều gồm nhiều bưu điện theo mà Ừ nếu nên là em đặt à huyết tấn cả sau
tất ở đấy nó bị bất hợp lý rồi cô gái bị nhầm rồi nó cả thêm một cái
nữa anh anh anh thấy em cũng bị dính đó là
tên cột không cần nhắc lại tên bảng Nói chung là thức là bên sửa thì ra cũng sửa
hết toàn bộ vào này Sửa bệnh nhiều phết là thôi chút kinh nghiệm về vụ này thôi
cho anh nhưng mà em sẽ rút kinh nghiệm mấy cái vụ này để mà về xong Thiết kế ra
tao bây lại cho hợp lý đấy ạ Ừ ok B trăm demo
đi đái phải nói phải nói xô thể trước đây
vì thực thể có trước cơ sở Niệm Ừ
ok xanh như xin demo luôn xanh này mua đi
Anh
đang nghe mẹ đây là Index ngoài
tính năng đăng nhập lại đăng ký thì nó sẽ vào đây trong đăng
nhập
Ok em cứ đăng nhập
lúc có cứ ở đây nó sẽ chia ra cân loại hết ra luôn mình giới thiệu thông tin có
thể sẽ ở đây không tin cá nhân thay đổi đổi mật khẩu Nó để mô tính năng đặt hàng
trước đi công tắc hẹn
khách hàng ở đây phải chọn sai
đây khách hàng có thể thay đổi họ tên số điện thoại địa chỉ Email ở đây luôn đợi
anh một tí Đợi em một tí Vừa nãy anh thấy sản phẩm của em có thể
chọn được nhiều sai đúng không ạ ông chủ nhật giờ đúng
em em lưu lại ở trong phải cột boresight mà nói đúng không trợ mẹ là một sản phẩm
có thể có nhiều sai đúng không cần nối nhau đúng cách cách nhau rồi cái gì nhỉ
nấu cắt nhau có yêu phận à Nếu mà cái sai này không ảnh hưởng đến
giá mới anh thấy giá nó chỉ có một mà đúng không
Khi bữa sau có ảnh hưởng tới giá luôn có à hãy có
Ừ thế em thử sang bên thử đặt hàng rồi
sang bên admin đáng xem lý thuyết minh
em lấy ở một đặt đang sản phẩm em có ghi rõ là cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy
ạ Và nếu mà em có chứa trách đây là nếu giá
Nếu dễ nhập hai giá trị đi thì Kích thước nó nhập một giá trị sẽ báo lỗi
Thế hả em kiểm tra của đã có hai giá phải có 2 kích thước
300 anh Nghĩa ở cái cách kiểu này người dùng Hơi khó dùng nhưng mà thôi Anh anh
cũng hiểu ý của em làm cái kiểu đấy cũng anh ấy từng làm rồi nhưng mà cái này
Thực ra em Em còn nhớ em thấy được là người dùng khó hiểu cái này đúng không
mọi người dùng còn sợ Mông lung là cách nhập như này thì trông sao anh hiểu cách
cách làm của em ok sạc sang bên đơn hàng đi
Ê thằng đội tiểu luôn anh em Em có kiểm tra vụ đơn Duyệt rồi
thì có ủi được chị đã có amin được khách là được hết
không không đơn Duyệt rồi thì có được phép gửi không
Ờ vậy được luôn hả Đơn Dương Thế chắc ít
admin là được hết ạ đơn giờ vẫn đùa thôi đã được con cá nhân viên thì không thể
bên em nữa hết à ok ok khi con còn gì muốn khoe nữa Anh thấy em
chắc thứ cho ông có vẻ họ ngon này làm việc với reason với mạng còn rồi này
nhưng mà có thống kê à ok rồi nhưng mà hỡi vì một cái là định hướng nó là cái
định hướng có vẻ ổn nhưng mà Ôi trời ơi ít nhắn tin hỏi anh thì anh
sẽ qua thế này có phải cái hôm nay thấy hơi hơi to a nó chả rút kinh nghiệm để
bán hai nhé chứ Anh thấy em làm một mình mà được mọi thứ như là rất ngon rồi
Ừ thôi Thế thôi nhỉ Còn Có gì cần trình bày đâu
em hết rồi mới có lỗi rồi Ok
anh thấy ổn rồi đấy thôi hôm nay kết thúc rồi nhé
nhóm nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ ạ
Bạn ấy làm tôi thấy khá ổn đấy chứ chẳng qua là cậu
làm một mình tôi nhớ lần cuối tin nhắn bạn ấy như cũng chẳng
anh cũng chẳng kiểm tra gì mấy ra ông ấy làm hơi
khi khởi loạn một tí nhưng sao định hướng đúng đấy là có
nhiều làm ngon hay ờ ờ nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ Mấy Nhóm kia đâu
hết rồi
Em hãy mấy ông phải đâu người ta làm mình ổn mà
ở nhóm chí này nhóm 7 đấy ngắm 22 U17 13 đâu hết rồi
Anh bảo vệ bảo vệ để hôm thứ bảy đỡ nào
gì hả Tôi là thế Hỏi em chỉa đồ ăn 2 tư cho
phép mày Ông cứ là một mình hết nhé Ừ nếu phải quay làm việc theo nhóm ở vì
đi làm mấy ông làm việc nhóm hả Mấy ông là xong mà mình cân tất cả được Nếu như
mà quan trọng là ở Đó là một mình thì đưa cho ông cầm chẳng
cần phải cãi nhau thằng nào cả ông chẳng phải trông đợi hoa đào không phải tự lực
cánh sinh thì ông sẽ phát triển ở nhiều cái
Ừ thế là tôi phải Lý Tưởng vẫn là hai người hai người sẽ có đây việc để làm
khi nhóm ba người không biết phân chia ra luôn
ờ ờ mày Nhóm kia đâu hết rồi alo
ở nhóm 9 rồi
39 359 của nhà lớp trưởng lớp trưởng bay xử
rồi Củi khô chạy mất tích rồi Ừ ok
nhóm mà a tiếp theo nhóm A
ở nhóm 7 ở nhóm 7 thì hả bạn Linh dạo này có mất
tích đâu rồi Hình như là ai Bạn này gần đấy ghét tôi vậy
a tiếp theo nhóm A U22
ở nhóm 22 thấy các bạn đấy bảo là vừa mới nhắn là tuần sau xin chào xin Sao
bảo vệ được hai ok là ma hay bảo vệ đợt 2
Khi Gà báo lại bảo muộn thì tôi vẫn sẽ mua gạch hôm nay mới bắt đầu báo
nhóm 17A nghe tiếng ai vậy Nhóm 17
a57 có nhỉ
anh alo alo khỏi giật mình ok em Ừ anh em đeo tai nghe đậu xanh
các bạn bè When đâu mất tiêu luôn rồi anh ngắm em nhóm ấy nhá Mua 7
Thế hả em hỏi anh thế Không phải trả lời nha à
cho đỡ em nhắn tin nữ ba mẹ em phải xin số có đi tin nhắn thôi
không hiệu quả đâu à A
và nhóm cuối nhóm 13
Ê mấy ông 9:30 mà không có nhóm nào thì tôi kết
thúc đấy
à à ừ ừ
ở nhóm 13 bạn kia bạn có việc gia đình như sao ạ
anh hả khi người ông Cường xuất nhỉ
em không biết à à à
Ừ ok Nói chung ơi thế Thật ra thiệt mà em thôi hôm thứ bảy bảo vệ thật mà nói
bậy mà không biết cách như thế nào chứ anh khó
Ừ đợi ngắm em thấy em rồi
Ừ ok à mà Vậy thử lần thứ hai Thầy Thím
thế hả Linh Tự nhiên ghét tôi à về hai tội nói mày tái liên quan nhạy cảm với
con gái bà ghét à Tôi có ơi Nhắn tin Bạn ơi cái gì đâu nhỉ
ạ Bạn ấy có thể là
thấy không phù hợp này nữa không biết nữa
cho tôi thấy được mà thì kệ Giá
hai đứa con gái một phần ở cũng đôi khi hơi
bị cảm xúc chi phối mà Tôi thấy chán cái gì ở tự nhiên bỏ luôn học bỏ mọi thứ
vì tội từng quen à ờ ờ cũng có bạn nữ cũng học cùng tôi rồi
trước họp giữa Khả luôn bạn đấy không cảm thấy bạn phá đâu mà mấy bạn nữ đôi
khi hơi tự ti quái cho tôi cảm thấy bạn học sự Khánh chị em bạn lấy cậu em thấy
tự nhiên mà em bảo có khi tôi không đeo ngày này Xóa bỏ
vì nó không biết được bạn ấy gặp những vấn đề gì cơ nhưng mà về các
bạn học trên lớp Tôi thấy rất là khác ý là tôi rất nể những các bạn nữ thì tôi
từ đó sẽ rất dễ mấy bạn nữ hợp công nghệ thông tin
anh alo alo thì thấy có nói này hả bây giờ pin bây giờ nhớ em cứ cho anh
luôn luôn Ừ ok
Em chào thầy và các bạn
nhóm mình là ngắm 17 về chủ đề bán quần áo số áo anh ép màn
hình F5 F5 mình mình tên là Hà nhỉ nhĩ Trung Thiện
trưởng nhóm bạn Bạn Đồng Hành là những vụ mặt hàng
lý do chọn đề tài là tại huyện thương mại điện tử phát triển hiện nay thì
ai cũng nhu cầu xài công nghệ thông tin rất là rất là nhiều cho nên là
phải hết dùng công nhưng mà điện tử vào muốn mở rộng thương hiệu Dell quốc tế để
cạnh tranh để mở rộng sản phẩm cả canh muối quốc tế
cho thuận tiện trong việc sử dụng quản lý tính toán
tính toán chính xác kiếp khi sex em hết
tiền lương đây là kho bông về vợ chích tặng
vợ giúp cho người dùng dễ tiếp cận với ạ khi
mua sản phẩm hơn thông quen việc quảng cáo hay là làm gì đó
tôi không áp dụng thì ngắm em sử dụng hết cái tờ đi Tim Em ccs
behappy 7.4.0 deadswitch 1.8.5 msw 8.0.16 3.6.0
[âm nhạc] Ê mày đã từng sử dụng lành do có khách
hàng có tài khoản mà khách hàng không cần tài khoản nhân viên và quản lý
chức năng chức năng của từng đối tượng từng
đối tượng là khách hàng hóa tài khoản này có thể đăng ký xem tất cả sản phẩm
quản lý do hành khách hàng có tài khoản thì giống tính
năng của các bạn không có tài khoản và Thêm là đặt hàng đăng nhậpđăng xứng
đáng gì hết xin ngân hàng đã đặt và nhân viên gì Đăng nhập đăng xuất quản
lý sản phẩm thay đổi lớn hàng thay đổi tình trạng đơn hàng
quản lý cái gì đầy đủ các chức năng của nhân viên và quản lý sản xuất quản lý
nhân viên à em về sơ đồ dở thì đừng có
etamine [âm nhạc]
cho mình về mình có kiếp hàng các em thì chỉ có thể tao thì có thể đọc được nhiều
nhiều nhưng sản phẩm Nga có
thưởng như sản xuất là có thể một nhà sản xuất có thể có nhiều sản phẩm
về thể loại thì 11 thay đổi có thể thuộc mộc một thể loại có thể tụ nhiều sản
phẩm về à mã
sản phẩm thì có thể thuộc nhiều vào cho nó có thể dùng nhiều hóa đơn hóa đơn có
thể tục nghiệm sản phẩm ở
bình luận sản phẩm đi một cái không thể bình luận được được sản phẩm
có thể bình luận trên di sản phẩm có thể bất động được nhiều nhưng mà mình trên
sản phẩm đó
vì chỉ có hình mình sẽ quyết định quay quay quay lại cái vừa rồi thì hai cái
nhìn ra được chỗ nào ạ Anh
không à Cái đầu tiên là [âm nhạc]
cái comment thì có thể nó thực thể được có có thể tính là được thể chứ không
phải là cái say lắm nhưng còn catalo đi theo rồi Chắc là nó sai này một sản phẩm
có nhiều thể loại đúng không và một thể loại có có nhiều sản phẩm đúng không Thì
thì nó là mối quan hệ 1-n một nở giữa hai hàng thôi
chứ không phải là tạp âm thể thực hệ chúng gian nữa nó tạo ra một bản trung
gian chứ có phải một cái thể trung gian đây thì cái cậu là thích cái nên là chỉ
là 11 thôi đúng không Không các tele là núi thả Cô Đắc thôi xóa cái phạm tôi đi
theo lấy là cái này cái thằng này là không phải là thực thể đầu Ngô nó và
thực thể đấy Em hiểu không ạ Ừ đấy Tiếp theo là
cái customer với mô đắp ấy thì em có thể tạo thằng Trung Thanh niên kia cũng được
hoặc là hoặc là bản chất là nó là mối quan hệ giữa customer với vô Đắc thôi
chả qua là một thằng khách hàng anh có thể có nhổ nhiều bình luận về sản
phẩm và một dòng sản phẩm có thể có nhiều bình luận bởi khách hàng
Ừ nhưng mà thôi Anh anh Nghĩa ở bình luận nó cỡ trung gian kiểu kia cũng được
không không không không xa Ừ ok
Ừ nếu mà comment đấy thì cài đặt tên con me rồi không cần phải có
máy có đắng đâu Ừ ok ok tiếp tiếp tiếp
từ hôm nay em mời bạn bánh đằng kia trên 7 bạn hàng trên mạng và thiết bị
anh alo alo anh trở về mày nghe rõ không Ok Ok
à Dạ thì [âm nhạc]
hết sản phẩm của bên em sẽ được lưu vào cảnh
cơ bản đồ đất ở ở đây có một à ở
nhà sản xuất và nhà sản xuất và và thể loại thì sẽ được nối với bản
calories viettel-ca tivi và Tại vì đây là có vấn đề hay cốc nên là em chia
thành hai bạn cho đi theo lời ca dâng riêng và một bạn là bạn của nhà sản xuất
thì
khi khách hàng đặt hàng thì sẽ đưa thông tin địa chỉ và thông tin sản phẩm cái
hàng Đạt là vào Viettel hoa được
số Viettel qua đời thì để nói với cả đời là
thế là sẽ lưu qua các thông tin chi tiết còn phải đi theo
sẽ liên qua và lại đơn hàng bà sản phẩm là số lượng mà
sai và
khi khách hàng đã càng thành công thì cái hàng sẽ đánh giá sản phẩm của mình
và đánh giá nó sẽ đưa vào đánh giá sản phẩm đã mua vào cái bảng có
mình vừa đất thì có thời gian và số số sau đánh giá và thành nội dung
hi vọng ca khách hàng còn bạn ko bắt buộc
là khi cách hàng quên mật khẩu của mình và khách hàng những thay đổi thì sẽ đặt
ra câu chuyện và gửi về email còn cả các pin là để luôn
các tài khoản của Admin Anh thấy em trình bày khá đầy đủ nhưng
mà do là giọng nắng hơi ở ngoài cho ta sẽ lại nói nhiều alo alo 000 giọng Alo
em nghe thấy anh không anh alo em à
nghe giọng em đang hơi bị chậm quá đấy thải
ra hơi khó nghe thì thôi nhưng mà nhà nghè anh anh thấy
được được nó thế rồi Dạ
em chào chị bạn thấy ổn rồi nhưng mà cười anh Anh vừa nãy anh bị nhầm anh anh
hiểu nhầm cái cách EZ của bạn kia lên thời ra anh bảo em thiết kế thực thể sai
nhưng B anh xem cơ sở dữ liệu thì có vẻ chưa kể cơ thực thể đúng rồi đấy cho
không say không ok à em gọi cho tư thế bọn em ổn ổn đoạn này
rồi à
anh ạ
ừ ừ
ừ ừ ừ ừ
Anh
mơ thấy thịt người ở chị đã màn hình tránh em ạ
anh ở đây ê ê
Anh vào nhà tớ chưa thấy chưa Ok Ok Vậy em
thì tối trang web thì khách hàng đối với khách hàng chưa có
tài khoản thì cách thì sẽ xem được sản phẩm và
và thêm thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng chị sẽ có thông báo về khi thành lập Mua
bấm mua ngay thì nó sẽ chuyển tới sẽ thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng và chỉ tác
giả hàng cho mình và đó là khách hàng muốn đặt hàng thì chắc hẹn bắt buộc phải
có thể phản ứng gì ở
Lạng Sơn à à à
xe khách hàng
hẹn chưa chưa có tài khoản thì biết khi đặt hàng sẽ hiện ra
ý kiến của đèn led à
ừ ừ
em
[âm nhạc]
hết đâu rồi ở nhà thờ ở đang đi giải quyết tiến sau
khi
giá lúa
khi cái thằng muốn mua hàng thì bắt buộc phải đăng nhập
mật khẩu đăng nhập thì em chỉ mắc quá Tên đăng nhập của mày kia à
vì hiện nay thì ở đây có Valdes email ví dụ nhập email sai
hay cấu trúc thì nó sẽ với
thông báo email không hợp lệ
khi đang trên đăng ký thì em cũng ra đi đây Zen
không có biết được đặc biệt là email và ép Lệ Á
em về số điện thoại thì cũng phải nhập số điện thoại của Việt Nam thì mới có
thể đăng nhập 12345 thì nó là số điện thoại không hợp lệ và không được
để trống còn giới tính thì ngày sinh và địa chỉ thì làm cái này không bắt buộc
nên là khách hàng của nhập gì cũng được
hôm nay có trang quên mật khẩu thì chứ nhập Email thì sẽ gửi một ít liên kết về
sự ngưỡng mộ tính cách về nghe của mình và có thể
dùng sẽ đổi mật khẩu trong trái tim hết đó ừ ừ
khi cài đặt em đăng nhập ở ở
Việt Nam khi đặt hàng ở đây sẽ hiện ra các thông tin mà người
dùng để nhập giáo dục em chưa nhập thì đó là đủ thông tin
Ừ thì khi em đặt hàng thì đó thực hiện thành công là
ở bên đây thì thì vô mục tài khoản sẽ có một ngân hàng
thì có sẽ sau cho mình Các đơn hàng rồi đang chuẩn bị và các em gầy guộc đã gửi
ít
dùng em muốn hủy đơn hàng thì ở đây có chủ tịch ngân hàng hoặc là ấm cho xem
chi tiết và hủy đơn hàng cho
NX Ok anh vừa thấy em em em thử để mô thủ
em còn một đánh giá sinh phẩm ok
anh ạ
Em à em biết chuyện đánh giá cho sản phẩm
của đơn đã đạt tới thành phố Vừa nãy anh nghe câu lời mình hỏi là em em kiểm tra
cầu gì về biệt Đáng lẽ là thưởng em phải nối cái phố Đắc ID của cái comment ý đến
bảng hóa đơn chi tiết chứ không phải ở hội Nội đến bảng có lắp đâu bởi vì a
Theo quy tắc là chuẩn là họ phải có đơn mà nó ngon thì mấy giờ đánh giá và đúng
không phải nói ra nhưng mà đơn chi tiết gì à
Ok anh thấy ổn rồi đấy con còn tính năng gì
nữa không ngờ
giờ hết rồi có thay đổi thông tin cá nhân Với đổi mật khẩu
thì
em nhiều nhớ rồi à anh
alo tí nữa chị ạ
A
BAD Minh em kiểm tra Anh kiểm tra Email với em mật khẩu
chỉ gồm có xem kết sẽ lỗi là danh mục
i9000 phụ có thể thêm sẽ rồi à
về quản lý sử dụng
sản phẩm có thể tìm kiếm sửa xóa sản phẩm để thêm sản phẩm đi
ok rồi anh anh thấy có vẻ có nhiều tính năng rồi Bây giờ anh bắt đầu họ thêm nhá
Ờ ờ Ừ cái sản phẩm em có xóa sản phẩm đã đạt
đã được đặt trong hóa đơn ngày sao cái cá nó sản phẩm nào mà để đạt trong
hóa đơn của Thế thì em sẽ hiểu được tìm thấy cô đơn
như cái quần này à à
chích khi mà xóa thì sẽ thông báo sản phẩm này kiểu kendam được bán ra thì
không xóa được à ok ok ok Nó ảnh hưởng đến khó có ngòi ok đủ thôi
Thế thì cái danh mục của em em nhập thêm danh
mục của nó vào menu của bên giao diện khách hàng đúng không nghỉ à
Ừ chắc vậy chắc chết đúng rồi tại vì cái bữa em là người sẽ có cái này nó sẽ có
kia này còn bạn kia thì bạn chỉ lấy thu đầu ra đâu mà ngon rồi bạn sẽ làm
các vậy chứ em không có những nhóm tế bào nên như em nghĩ tạo ra thì chắc lúc
bên kia nó cũng Chị chị đang được Ừ nhưng mà bạn em chưa tới hạn thì không ạ
Bây giờ tạo tận hai chục cái danh mục là bao nhiêu cái Menu bị tràn đúng không
Chắc bị che cái à Ừ ok
xã bên sang bên đơn hàng đi xem như thế nào em cũng đã kiểm tra vụ duyệt đội
không được nghỉ không ở
bên phòng bắt tin thì em chưa Nhưng mà chịu làm về
mặt giao diện thì nó cho ok
tìm kiếm em tìm kiếm theo về gì nhỉ Cứ trêu hơn với đi Thôi tao đi bên em
không có điều trị hết anh theo số thứ tự trong một cái mương này cũng không có để
kiểu mà lên nữa ừ nên có mã đơn thì anh thấy hợp lý hơn rồi khách hàng nó bình
thường anh xem theo mã đơn Ừ ok ở đây là cái phải ưu tiên phải sắp
xếp theo phải trạng thái rồi mà sắp xếp theo thời gian bởi vì ở đây anh thấy à
em nói chị sắp xếp lại thời gian nên thành ra cái đốt đã duyệt nó vẫn còn
trên là đơn mới đọc thế được ra không ổn đúng không để sắp xếp theo từng cặp
trước đấy đấy Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là để anh thử bấm xem một đơn với em Em hiểu
Bấm vào xem mẫu đơn đem đổi ID trên kia là 100 nha
À em Em có vay đến kiểm tra rồi đúng không
em cũng nhớ là mình xem có nhiều chim đơn
mà nó nó để tồn tại thì nó có thể quay lại cho con nhưng tôi chỉ đơn nó không
tồn tại vì nó còn đất nó chỉ bán cái lỗi anh cứ đâu đấy nó
có nó để có đây rồi thì nó sẽ theo cái đi
anh thấy có kiểm tra tốt rồi anh anh thấy à
Ừ nếu mà có xóa được bản thân Không anh ạ
[Vỗ tay]
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
Ừ
ông Beo ổn Face không biết hình ở nhóm mà
Anh nhớ nhóm nào đấy
khi con nhóm mà muốn bảo vệ không nhỉ
thì các bạn kiểm tra veddet cả bác em thế là ổn rồi nhưng mày yên tâm tôi vẫn
còn nhiều cơ hội dự bị cho mùa Đã vậy thử lắm nếu không có sẵn sàng hết đi ừ
khi con còn nhóm nào nữa nhỉ nốt một nhóm đi
anh ngắm vừa nãy nhóm 10
a13 U13 thì có việc rồi gửi bài
U17 này 17 có thiện có I burn burn burn đây đúng không
thoát rồi
anh hả Em đừng có sửa code gì mấy nhá Mấy ông
ngồi sửa giờ lại lỗi tùm lum đấy
em hết nhỏ xin bảo vệ thử được không ở dưới gì à Hôm nay chắc là tạm kết thúc
rồi bảo hôm Sao bảo vệ thật mấy ông nên có đủ nhé á
Ừ ok nhỉ
khi sex Em Tội Nghiệp mấy cái bạn kia mày cũng
có anh có nhóm 2 bạn thì mà bạn có mặt ở đây 1 bạn thì có việc đột xuất đúng
không em nhờ các bạn cũng phải chuẩn bị các
thứ nhé Chuẩn bị các thứ tôi có dặn trước đấy nên mấy bạn được được quyền mở
hẳn một cái cửa sổ bên cạnh rồi nhìn rồi đấy đọc cũng được mà đọc ý chính nốt các
sư thủy Ừ Ok
thôi Tại sao hôm nay thế thôi chả bạn nhé
ừ ừ